ça doit fonctionner
et aller on va essayer d'aller suivre
ce 3960 alors attendez
on est censé avoir les caméras
on a fab qui va arriver j'imagine
rapidement et je lâche juste en train de
dire pourquoi j'ai pas les cames
ah ok j'ai pas la cam
parce que OK
il me manque il me manque une adresse
pour la cam
attendez on va la récupérer
on a bien fait de lancer un peu en
avance
les filles qui est lui on va la voir
facilement
les
on l'a
ttendez il faut que je récupère les
caméras
attendez
ok je les ai ici
ok on va réussir à choper la cam on va
choper Fab
en espérant que ça fasse pas bug les
cames ça me fait toujours peur
on a fab ça lui Fab allô tu m'entends
allô on entend Fab mais c'est Fab qui
nous entend peut-être pas
c'est Fabien
ça va ouais je suis en train de
récupérer les caméras
et toi ça va
je suis en train de
mettre ça en place
alors comment ça marche aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y a un match piano en même
temps
logique mais c'est cool parce que c'est
bien que ce soit en même temps en fait
on voit la même position traiter de
manière différente
ouais puis un match dure quand même je
te cache pas que ça dure 6 heures quand
même un match ok
non mais tu vois c'est pour être enfin
sinon on n'est pas assez sûr donc je te
cache pas que si c'était un après
l'autre ce sera un peu compliqué pour
tout le monde voilà
match aujourd'hui le truc c'est que
c'était la même durée pour les poules
donc en fait ouais enfin tu pars vite
dans les deux trois mois de tournoi donc
ouais en fait ils ont raison ils ont
décidé de de toujours en même temps et
je pense que demain il y aura le match
pour la troisième place aussi en même
temps important
donc ça c'est quand même quand même les
bonnes nouvelles d'entrée
il y a une pause on va commencer
ouais alors il y a des pauses il y a des
préparations des trucs mais là je suis
en train d'essayer de mettre les cames
Fab ok vas-y vas-y fais donc moi je
discute un peu
discuter donc
mais oui non non c'est ça joue en même
temps
je t'entends pas discuter ah ouais non
bah je sais pas je discute avec toi quoi
ah oui oui non ok ça n'a aucun sens
absolument aucun rapport en fait
OK et c'est quoi c'est des matchs en
quatre parties ouais en quatre parties
ouais non bien sûr pourquoi pas moi je
sais pas
attends je suis en train de récupérer
alors j'ai quelques caméras mais j'en ai
peut-être d'autres
je suis en train de les mettre celle que
j'ai et je peux peut-être en avoir
d'autres
je crois que j'ai des caméras gros plan
échiquier là je suis très heureux on
voit bien les filles comme ça
j'ai demandé à
fermer la fenêtre
je suis en train de les mettre
j'ai les quatre cam
et c'est du coup c'est quoi les matchs
alors les matchs je vais te dire c'est
Nakamura
ok
donc je sais pas ce que tu préfères
suivre
peut-être Carlson nepo en premier
je préfère rien en fait
on peut faire Carlson n'est pas puis on
voit un peu comment ça se passe là je
vois des pauvres Carlsen je joue à la
cam
ils ont l'air très heureux
très concentré avant de son premier coup
il est très heureux non et donc en fait
c'est quoi il joue deux fois la même
position une fois que les blancs
ils ont une nouvelle position et ils
reviennent donc un quart d'heure et il
revienne
que
c'est beau hein
très belle ville très belle ville et les
petits sponsors derrière on est très
très bien il y a un peu de chaises comme
il y a un peu de litchi
donc ça c'est beau aussi
je sais pas s'il y a du chez sable ou
pas mais il y a il y a du sponsor
derrière avec regarde le petit roller là
magnifique
quand même je pense qu'il y a bien une
tête même une cinquantaine de personnes
dans la salle bah oui c'est bien du
monde c'est bien regarde il y a la
petite fille qui vient jouer le premier
coup n'est poétrez très heureux car ils
sont tous très heureux allez hop on
vient faire le premier coucou oh bah oui
ah bah ça hésite quand même
ah bah bravo ah bah voilà un beau début
de
ah bah tu vois
et très heureux Magnus aussi
une
cam il y a des pots qui se marquent le
scène aussi
bon enfant
si on doit savoir mais en fait on n'a
jamais su et ben voilà et ben tu l'as
Fab le premier coup Detroit
à moins sur la petite non alors pas du
tout
ok bon alors ok 960 un truc qui font
tout le temps ils essaient d'activer
leur donc
il y a pas d'impro à 7 c'est protégé
parce que ça arrive des fois qu'il
puisse aller moi ça m'est arrivé une
fois il y avait genre un fou un cavalier
hop tu perds la le pion et la tour
terminé même deux coups en fait
bon
belle position mon Fab n'est pas il joue
tempo même à ce jeu en fait ouais mais
ils ont eu la position quand même un
quart d'heure avant donc bon il en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] by menace déjà
qui est ah ouais attention au cavaliers
[Musique]
tu penses qui favorit en 960 abdosa
torov peut-être qui a fait un gros score
il était à 9h30 sur 10 quand même ouais
ouais j'ai vu les partenariats
[Musique]
j'en sais rien en fait enfin je sais pas
si fort ou si tu vois en poule ça joue
léger je sais pas
les gens qui ont voient pas super bien
moi je trouve qu'on voit bien
franchement qu'est-ce qu'on voit mal je
sais pas là je crois qu'on a une belle
au contraire
bon on voit bien les joueurs on voit
bien le mec qui caméra ami ou la nana
d'ailleurs
je pense c'est plutôt de la photo
c'est quoi le temps 23 minutes 25
minutes chacun c'est franchement plus
j'ai regardé le setup pour être mon côté
je peux mettre les chic un peu plus
grand mais j'ai regardé le setup de mon
côté avec le téléphone franchement on
voit bien bah
après tu peux faire l'inverse c'est ça
mettre les pieds mais c'est dommage
l'échiquier franchement on voit au moins
on voit les joueurs en grand c'est cool
ils ont combien de temps là ils ont 25
minutes et après il y a 5 minutes de
rajouter du coup alors là ne me demande
pas pourquoi le 30e mais
je suis heureux
sur eux du rajoute mais après il y a
qu'un seul rajout de 5 minutes au 30e il
y a pas de rajout 40 ou 50e
malheureusement c'est dommage on n'est
pas super sûr
moi j'aurais peut-être ajouter 5 minutes
tous les 10 coups mais après voilà c'est
pas moi qui fait les cadences Fab mais
non c'est dommage j'aurais bien remis un
petit peu de un petit peu de un petit
peu plus de temps
en tout cas là ça réfléchit et ib3 ça a
l'air de poser problème bah écoute
développement du coup tu vas te demander
est-ce que je fais cavalier
je te prends tout Français
[Musique]
serait tellement heureux de faire une
partie comme ça non non on serait grand
sourire
un épaule je crois qu'il réfléchit à se
lever regarde il veut se barrer regarde
ils ont tous les mêmes fauteuils
sont un peu petits je trouve je pense
pas que c'est pas ça pas l'air très
confortable non le dossier a l'air un
peu un peu court
rétractable je sais pas dans le chat
possible
qui vivrait peut-être un petit peu trois
son goût mais il a pris G4 écoute
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on va faire grand rock ou pas
avec les Blancs je sais pas
ouais il y a des chances quand même
enfin on verra quand mais parce que ça a
l'air un peu compromis quoi j'ai envie
de dire enfin on peut aussi rester là
mais oui la tourte aura du mal à
l'activer
ça me prend j'ai 4
j'aime pas trop ce développement des
blancs mais d'un autre côté il a
beaucoup d'activités
mais la dame je la trouve un peu bizarre
en geai quattro voilà alors peut-être
qu'elle est bizarre on a l'habitude du
jeu d'échec et qui a foncé vite là bon
c'est pas faux
en fait peut-être que c'est pas grave
ici spécifiquement on va dire on n'a pas
envie de prendre le centre de quoi trop
ouais
on peut faire quatre cinq peut-être
qu'on est très heureux on ferme le foie
prendre l'espace
tu peux pas jouer des 5 non plus parce
que mon cahier aussi ça
des ouais voilà enfin
le cheval
donc c'est un peu con peut-être soit
soit tu fais comme lui
peut-être je sais pas
c'est complexe en fait juste
joli coup de dépôt j'aime bien là j'aime
bien il tape un peu partout là il tape
il tape il tape il tape il tape il tape
déjà en sueur après quatre coups
tu sais même pas pourquoi en fait
tu comprends enfin pourquoi tu es dans
la merde en fait
mais non mais en tout cas c'est assez
logique ce qu'il a fait au début je dois
dire
j'ai quatre il ouvre le fou qui a B3 bah
il fait jouer le cavalier qui était au
coin et qui faisait rien donc
donc c'est assez logiquement jouer de la
part des deux hommes Magnus aussi mais
il te retrouve enfin en difficulté après
tu peux faire cavalier il y a pas mort
d'homme non non
c'est 5 toi tu auras pas le même en C4
qui va te faire des trois ou trois ou ce
qu'il veut l'un ou l'autre
peut-être même B3 qui est un peu bizarre
du fait que tu es pas alfonction kéto
mais tu bloques quand même deux chevaux
quoi
et puis en B3 il est beau
c'est un genre de double coupage
d'oreille là
il a fait qu'il y a des 6 kb3 il y aura
absolument rien à [ __ ] n'est pas tempo
juste je pense qu'il en a rien à [ __ ]
en fait
car le sel il doit être sué quoi dire le
mec en face on a absolument rien à
[ __ ]
c'est quoi le risque de dames c'est 5
quel nom
j'aurais jamais même envisagé le coup
ta dame en fait elle va pas elle peut
pas rester stable ici non mais un
cavalier on s'écape par contre pour
attaquer B2 pourquoi pas
peut-être un jour je pense qu'ils vont
faire juste ces trois
mais après peut-être grand rock
et 4 5
mais je pense qu'il a raison de jouer
tempo dans le sens où de toute façon
j'en sais rien ouais tu sais pas en fait
donc qui t'a pas savoir autant tu
cliques
c'est pas idiot en soi
tu en as absolument rien à [ __ ] en
fait
il a fait
trois tempo dans la gueule et on a
absolument rien à [ __ ] c'est
magnifique en fait
extraordinaire bravo m'envoie c'est
peut-être la méta du genre en fait les
autres réfléchissent oui c'est compliqué
les pièces on sait pas où elles sont où
bon arrête juste tu cliques
il est complètement magnifique n'est pas
bon après il va perdre probablement à
force de faire ça mais avec panache
ou 100 Nash
elle était pas mal
[Musique]
quel que soit le jeu il fait ça en fait
rien à [ __ ] mais je sais pas comment
il réussit à pas faire de couilles en
fait
ouais mais il en fait
[Musique]
juste il te joue tout au hasard tout le
temps et il tombe souvent bien
est-ce que ça compte pour la relo non
pas du tout
là je sais pas s'il va pas dû le prévoir
il doit être très content Magnus regarde
tu vas pas pouvoir jouer tempo celui-là
et ce qui menace quelque chose
peut-être B6 c'est à 4 quoi mais si ça
complètement
il a réfléchi de 30 secondes
mais ce que un jour tu as pas de
cavaliers aussi cela
et comment tu pars ça oh c'est beau
regarde tu fais faux F7 à me prendre
cette maths
on serait très heureux
quand tu pars ça bon
parce que grand rock
[Musique]
bon maintenant que tu as joué à 5
peut-être chelou mais bon
on a réellement rien à [ __ ] de rien
et peut-être je veux le faire en deux
temps B3 puis enfin
je sais pas
la position est tellement étrange
mais c'est vrai que ça devient
concession c'est pour faire
on est d'accord donc c'est probablement
pas le meilleur et les quatre ans
j'y pensais mais après bon tu dois la
paire de fou mais d'un autre côté la
position est tellement bizarre
le truc
tu auras tout de suite à 5 en l'air
pour tu as vu le numéro 1 de l'ordi
cavalier à 3 avec qui des pions prend
dame prend à deux
ouais bon B6
[Musique]
c'est le problème 1960 c'est que les
pièces sont tellement bizarrement
agencés qui a des choses
au cas où pas même Staline
et interdit
[Musique]
quand même très limite enfin limité non
c'est forcément si tu vois que ça marche
tu le fais mais allez calculer cavaliers
à 3 qui au mieux si ça fonctionne
interdit juste le rock que les Blancs
peut-être même pas envie de faire
c'est plutôt B6 non le coup
parce que ce cavalier au final on n'a
pas très envie de le tolérer plus
longtemps non
en fait c'est ça c'est une bonne
question
même stratégiquement parlant je veux
dire outre les coups concrets
[Musique]
il y a pas de stratégie là mon Fab dans
salle là je crois
je crois que c'est que non
ouais mais à un moment c'est bien de
savoir et quelle structure
c'est autant tu as des parties en 960
tout ça ou tu as des concepts et ça
ressemble vite à quelque chose et c'est
stratégiquement c'est intéressant autant
là j'ai l'impression que c'est que du
coup par coup
ouais
la masse centrale
ouais mais c'est tellement contrebalancé
par tu vois genre
c'est une question c'est cavalier 3
comment tu défends le pion est-ce que
c'est fou F2 je pense tu as pas trop le
choix
mais oui oui il y a des trucs partout
tout le temps
à deux qui peut être en l'air sur sur
une découverte comme on l'a vu avec le
cavalier A3 donc il sera pas joué mais
qui peut être une idée d'attente quand
même d'un autre côté comme tu lis s'il
est blanc en fait c'est plutôt ici les
blancs réussissent à chasser toutes les
pièces noires ça va
ça peut aller vite c'était pas à la
fuite
ça dégage tu t'attends fout de case noir
qui peut aller faire un tour vers H4 tu
as E4 qui partent
tu as beaucoup de ressorts tu as
peut-être même petit rock un jour
avec le foie H1 qui qui surveille tout
donc
[Musique]
perdre déjà on peut aller voir
c'est ici je vais essayer de choper
la cam
ah il y a que 5 coups dans celle-là
absolument rien à [ __ ] d'où ça t'auras
mais il est impressionnant ça t'auras
dans ce jeu
après c'est comme je disais dans le live
c'était avant-hier c'est pas si étonnant
que ça dans le sens où il a tout le
temps des poubelles en langue et il est
bon pour pour arnaquer en gros et
trouver les ressources oui c'est ça et
là en fait c'est juste qu'il a une
poubelle d'entrée mais son adversaire
aussi donc c'est poubelle versus
poubelle
et j'ai l'impression qu'il sort bien de
son jus
non mais je suis d'accord qu'il est
plutôt bien si la clé ça t'aurait fuite
il a sorti le bon cavalier en B6 enfin
le Caval est pourri du coin alors que la
car il a il est toujours au coin son
cavalien il a 0 15 voila donc il va
devoir perdre beaucoup de temps pour
l'emmener en jeu et elle a tant B4 on
sait pas trop ce qu'elle fait là enfin
quand il y a beaucoup de trucs qu'on a
pas trop aller dans sa position c'est
pas perdant comme position mais
simplement
on sent que les noirs et les noirs sont
sont à deux doigts d'être très bien
parce que oui cette tour B4 comme fable
le dit elle a pas de casse quoi et le
cavaler un il bouge pas enfin il va
perdre beaucoup de temps pour le sortir
donc d'ailleurs pourquoi il a pas 1000
cavalier ah en B3 et ben je sais pas
parce que au coup d'avant
c'est vrai que je sais pas un truc
peut-être que pareil t'aider à 5 à 4 non
mais pas du tout
aucune idée bref ok bon il est pas
encore foutu du tout mais oui bon j'ai
compris rapidement et ramener la tour en
jeu
on retourne sur Mac
ok bon
attends je crois qu'il y a eu des coups
je vais mettre un refresh
je crois qu'il y a
je crois qu'il y a un problème de
retransmission
il y a eu B3 cavaliers à trois et c'est
exactement c'est exactement les coups
donc j'imagine un qui pourra plus faire
grand rock ça c'est débile
ça paraît bizarre elle a fait juste
Orsay clairement le coup à jouer sur une
colonne et peut-être H5 je pense ça je
sais pas
avec et tu peux te déclouer au passage
en allant genre en G1 peut-être même ou
en G2 pour te conserver tu vois genre
sur H5 dames G2 G4 je vais peut-être
faire fout H4 petit roc et puis
et après 4 et tu envoies
moi j'ai l'impression que les Blancs un
gros avantage
ouais je sens mieux que les blancs
à l'abri quand il part par là
je dois E4
A4 on va dire je laisse dessine
et voilà le plan on va taper là on va
faire 5 on va on va faire deux trois
petites bricoles quand même dans une
petite mêlée qui pousse un moule
ouais
il y a pas de pièces en fait de ce côté
d'échiquier pour les Noirs donc quand le
roi il va partir par là quand même il
sera un peu ouvert
puis même comment tu réussis à le
chasser ok tu as encore deux fois deux
on défend des quatre et puis cinq fois
F2 et on dégage la dame on dégage tout
le monde
mais il n'y a pas d'harmonie côté noir
mais sûrement que quatre effort parce
que tu menaces aussi des cinq pour
l'envirer et tu menaces aussi peut-être
des E5 dans certains monde
mais oui
position pour pour le joueur russe
mais ce qui est spécifique au 960 bah en
fait non je crois pas
il pourrait il pourrait faire un
classement de 960 c'est un beau jeu il y
a pas de théorie tu rentres tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet dans les
échecs
et ça repart vraiment les cartes tu vois
un joueur comme Abdou sa torof qui est
un peu derrière en prépa il a fait faux
F2 alors là attention à vous promet
trois quand même
[Musique]
jolie pour prendre
en fait
ça c'est pas clair déjà
en fait c'est une grosse connerie mais
ça sent ça se voit ouais
non mais le jeu est réellement très dur
infable enfin tu connais
pas aussi d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que
je fais friv 2 mais euh
logique c'était qu'un autre champion E4
c'était hyper logique hein ça empêché
fou prend B3 et ça préparé des cinq
était ça défendait ça attaqué d'AVOIR
bravo donc l'idée c'est quoi c'est
cavalier.f4
et si tu veux pas te reprendre c'est le
match que tu as montré tout à l'heure on
va le remonter parce qu'il est vraiment
joli
matin étouffait mais grosse connerie
parce que pas logique en fait ouais il
va un peu à l'encontre du jeu
tu fais ou 4 tu te prends un truc comme
ça j'ai envie de dire bon bah ok c'est
pas un truc
très mal joué de la part de Yann
par contre ça c'est sûr
il y a même dame pour lui mais tu
reprends c'est clair qu'il y a plus de
débat c'est
déjà quasiment terminé
faut bouger la dame en fait ça va être
la position qu'on regarde tout à l'heure
mais en bien pire c'est ici dame prend
B3 roi E1 cavalier C2 tours
et on peut pas prendre la tour parce
qu'il y a du couloir et je sais même pas
ce qu'on peut jouer en fait
je sais même pas si on a un coup
peut-être eux quatre
bon mais à vrai dire c'est quoi tes
mêmes derrière matériel non
mauvaise partie de Yann qui fait un qui
faisait un bon début de partie mais là
la gaffe est
hallucinante
mais ce qu'il y a de bizarre c'est que 4
enfin je sais pas pourquoi il a rejeté
au 4 on profite de
donc je sais pas enfin ouais tu as
raison c'est sûrement qui veut faire
partir des
erreurs qui sont très facilement
explicables tu vois pas un coup sur un
machin bon mais là
c'était quand même assez téléphoné la
menace de Magnus après il se développait
comme il pouvait le joueur norvégien
mais le fouet
très clairement
appelé très clairement le fou prend B3
ce qui fait que ces deux ici ou pas
non par contre oui c'est vrai qu'il a
une défense en plus par rapport à ce
qu'on regarde avec la démarche 5 par
rapport à la dame en H3 ce qui peut
faire 3
du coup la Tour Eiffel participe pas les
forces du pion et tu peux commencer à
courir à 4 machin
[Musique]
tu vas encore pouvoir tenter deux trois
pièges quand même avec les Blancs
attention à 960 il faut vraiment être
très vigilant
Magnus qui réfléchit qui doit avoir
envie de d'en terminer plus vite qu'avec
cavalier ces deux mais il y a pas de
cookies
il va chercher la qualité et les peaux
qui va jouer aux trois tempo évidemment
donc il va reculer la tour alors
ça peut être une option
franchement oui enfin tu as trois pions
c'est bien
après ce qu'elle est si simple à gagner
ce centre blanc peut quand même gêner la
coordination des pièces noires
avoir mais après d'après ce que j'ai vu
avec la petite jauge sur dame bien je
crois qu'il y a eu deux
donc tu peux pas vraiment forcer les
changes l'échange des dames
faire un coup de tour genre tout fist
aurait fuite qui a value 5 et ça va et
ça va jouer
et côté Kaos
mais ce qu'il a tenu
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce bordel
c'est deux fous furieux en fait qui
s'affrontent
donc on était là à peu près ouais
bim
il y en a partout
bon écoute
je ne sais pas quoi c'est intéressant
B4 toi mais moi j'aurais pensé que je
suis bien avec les noirs
[Musique]
le truc d'après ce que je fais parce que
je comprends du coup avec les valves
c'est que le quatuor là de pièces est
très bien placé pour attaquer le roi et
tu as peut-être du mal avec les Noirs à
faire ces six grands rock qui te
permettrait de te descendre
ça doit pas être si facile de se mettre
en place en fait
oui
intéressant comme partie
mais il peut trouver ça évidemment je
crois qu'il est où c'est obligé de faire
ça en fait
non mais en plus il y a la famille il a
fait G5 ou il laisse le fou dans le coin
et c'est un truc comme ça autant faire
la dame ouais en plus il a eu
l'expérience de devoir calculer ça il y
a deux jours quoi
et là il se trouve qu'après dame F7 leur
dit de donner complètement gagnant
mais une nouvelle fois c'est on se rend
compte qu'on fait tellement d'erreurs à
ce jeu quand on appuie les ouvertures
pour nous guider et les plans qu'on a pu
étudier à la maison ça devient vraiment
un jeu de calcul pur et la différence
entre entre un humain et un ordinateur à
ce jeu est nettement plus grande qu'aux
échecs classique
pour nous guider effectivement et on a
un filtre pour trier les coups et donc
on se concentre sur certains coups on
calcule bien mais là en fait on a plus
rien pour se guider donc c'est que du
calcul
et donc vu que c'est la force de l'ordi
la différence encore plus large oui
la différence la différence c'est
nettement plus plus grande on va
remettre on va repartir sur Magnus à la
caméra
qui a une position très avantageux mais
pas encore gagné
qui peuvent encore faire le travail côté
des pots même si je donne pas cher de sa
peau aux joueurs au joueur russe
je suis d'accord je pense ça peut être
très vite très dur pour lui même si
perdre avec les blancs en 960 et un peu
moins grave là encore qu'aux échecs
normaux parce que c'est un jeu où tu
peux vraiment gagner avec les noirs
on n'a pas de variantes ou quoi on peut
fermer le jeu ici c'est on peut pas
forcer la nul avec les Blancs
après
un vrai bon Magnus
il a montré qu'il est bien là
ouais c'est pas champion pas numéro à
mondial depuis depuis 4 ans pour rien
donc la Tour Eiffel
j'imagine ouais cavalier au 5 ou roi E2
après comme tu disais en l'option A il
file vite mais il y a pas la tour
à 8 donc tu peux encore le bloquer
peut-être mettre deux trois marble sur
la route
ouais
tu te bloques au final
et après j'essaye de faire un peu de taf
avec la dame et les fous quoi
moi je partirai pour deux
personnellement
dans l'ordi me réfute complètement et
cavalier B5
ici je fais tourner il veut quoi OK
ah mais je me fais venger sur je me fais
venger sur H1
ok donc le coup qui paraît logique perd
instantanément
et donc c'est cavaliers 5 le coup
d'accord parce que ça empêche cavalier
C4 et ça prépare un peu de
on regarde un petit peu
on va pas se prendre une dame direct
mais
c'est trop
c'est trop après les pièces mineures ça
arrive qu'elle fasse qu'elle fasse des
blocus
il a joué cavalier 5 ok mais bon
joue cette finale tu sais souvent dans
la dans l'écossaise là avec avec deux
pièces mineures contre tour de pion
et il arrive que tu réussisses à bloquer
deux voire même trois pions avec un fou
un cavalier si tu réussis à les
apposition avec des sacs et 6 dessins là
ouais
et il arrive que tu les bloques en les
forçant à se mettre sur une couleur et
que tu arrives à placer tes deux pièces
mineures devant avec le roi
tu trouves une harmonie et que tu
bloques mais oui c'est assez particulier
et là dame G4 c'est pas mal joué je
trouve il prépare un peu de cavaliers C6
peut-être mais il y aura h 50 encore
pour dévier
quand on était petit
tu avais gagné non
elle est dure à gagner ouais ouais
[Musique]
elle est plutôt nul en fait complètement
nul en fait et ça va 4 tes machins par
là-bas
instantanément il veut dévier la dame
sur dame prend H5 il veut tourner F8 la
tour sera libérée de la protection du
pion il va commencer à préparer des
tours F2 tours F2 dame prend H1
non ça va être vite terminé ça va faire
dame de dame c'est un échange et cette
finale elle a l'air
quand tu es pas beau
tu es vraiment tu es vraiment
Au diable vauvert
c'est dans le trait dur
on peut peut-être aller voir la fin de
NACA d'où ça t'auras Fab je sais pas ça
a l'air d'être un peu plus il a pas un
peu mais bon qui est compliqué il a fait
cavalier il a fait quoi il a fait dames
Roissy 1
cavalier E5 et B3
E4 c'est la partie c'est la partie et
les positions compliquées alors le cas
tu vas enfermer le four à chat
bon ok GF il veut quoi
j'ai pas la ref
je n'ai pas la ref mon Fab
F ça a l'air logique pour faire après et
aussi pour voir la dame avec des dames
G5 des dames je sais pas où enfin H4
échec Internet
le grand rock je pense énormément à
faire grand rock histoire que la tour
participe au jeu
il va faire des cinq
il est dans le trait dur
il est dans le trait dur Nadia Beck
dommage qu'il avait une belle ouverture
et il allait se perdre un petit peu à
pas à pas revenir avec la dame
ouais
il fallait absolument Fab recourir vers
F7 avec cette dame et pas cessé enfermer
mais bon il a dû penser un petit peu
comme nous à tort que que ce sacrifice
était mauvais pour pour les blancs
passe déjà soit ne pas l'envisager parce
que c'est un thème bizarre quand même
il est bien 960 mais on le trouvera
rarement aux échecs normaux et
[Musique]
en plus même
une fois que le fait est-ce que quand tu
juges
on voit un peu trop le cavalier un loin
du jeu et on voit pas assez le quatuor
de pièces dont on a parlé un peu plus
tôt
qui est beau ce quatuor
un complexe complexe
faut aussi regarder des tactiques là
encore très inhabituels mais prise dame
décroît trop
j'essaie de comprendre tour d'ici je
leur dis donne pas d'imprimer 4 pourquoi
c'est juste une pièce
[Musique]
parce que il y a un cahier des cinq
mais je veux dire tu vois les pièges
sur le cavalier
là encore un son des choses que vous ne
verrez qu'en 960
donc il échange en F6
mais en plus j'ai ce qu'il y a de je
sais pas s'ils font ça tous les jours
mais il joue vraiment des positions
complètement folles aujourd'hui là je
sais pas si c'est le premier jour enfin
le jour où j'ai regardé il y a eu il y a
eu des positions folles et puis la
partie d'après c'était juste une finale
mais la finale était un peu folle aussi
avec mes pièces ça retombe et là en fait
pas du tout tellement dépend de la
position de départ tu vois c'est F4 G5
bon c'est pas direct en vrai quoi
ok
cool je pense qu'il va faire maintenant
mais bon je trouve que c'est une bonne
chance pratique pour nous dire bec
d'ailleurs c'est la partie on sait pas
trompé pas la première ligne de l'ordi
parce que l'ordi adore les blancs après
Fuger deux mais ok enfin c'est normal en
fait ce qui fait au lieu de se laisser
attaquer agresser il rejoue l'activité
c'est un jeu j'ai l'impression qu'il
faut quand même souvent jouer pour le
dynamisme
au dessus des pièces en fait
carreau vraiment très fort dans cette
partie ça a l'air dur de jouer de
manière bien positionnée parce que tu te
prends trop de peau de bananes partout
quoi
ok oui ok oui
qui fait mal mais plus que 5 minutes
j'aide juste un coup d'œil à la position
Fab de
mal en pire ça va être à trois dame
[Musique]
b252 mais bon voilà et il envoie non ça
je pense que la partie est déjà quasi
terminée ce qui est intéressant c'est
chez Naka on aura peut-être une finale
de rêve de main Fab entre 5 amours et
magnouche
ça peut être beau
cette partie est pas encore terminée
tout de même non bon il est bien
d'accord
[Musique]
il y a plus de potentiel de gaffe dans
la position de Naka dans celle de Magnus
en fait qui est un peu un peu trop
simple
ce qu'il a quand même des pions enfin il
a deux tours contre la dame actuellement
ils vont il va quand même faire une
pièce donc il aura deux tours deux pions
contre dame pièces donc et derrière mais
ça peut être trois pions peut-être
je sais pas après c'est vrai que 4 mais
faut voir dans l'enseignement s'il est
précis
ça peut
ça peut on va voir comment il s'en sort
ici
ouais ça paraît ça paraît juste mais bon
avec un peu de
réussite ça peut tourner
surtout qu'on le connaît un bec on
l'avait vu au championnat du monde
rapide qu'il avait remporté il est
capable de retourner des positions même
si là ça paraît quand même
très compromis
c'est un joueur dont il faut se méfier
et tu t'en méfie Fab
la tête est méfiante
c'est bien ce que je dis
cette position de Manu c'est pour ça un
thème de vidéo masterclass ou comment
créer un pion passé le pousser au waouh
sur la partie de Magnus quand même
pousse quoi c'est juste qu'il avait pu
passer et qui le pousse ouais c'est ça
moi ça me fait un peu penser à la partie
de Boris pas ce qui
avec son pion h mais bon vite fait
non mais c'est marrant que ça prenne pas
déjà que les échecs c'est trop compliqué
le 96 c'est encore pire
c'est pas grave
[Musique]
le 960 c'est encore plus plus difficile
à suivre
genre je veux dire c'est comme le paddle
quoi ça prend bien ouais mais c'est
facile comme je le panel au contraire la
balle quoi mais
il y a pas enfin tu vois ça sera
toujours moins regarder que que le vrai
tennis on s'en fout en fait du paddle
mais niveau amateur c'est sympa à jouer
court moins tu avais besoin de
d'exigences physiques et compagnie quoi
tu es tranquille ou tu fais ton petit
double tu prends la balle par derrière
c'est pareil enfin tu vois tu joues à
poser chèques sauf que tu as pas de
théorie enfin
non mais je suis d'accord avec toi en
fait moi je rejouerai peut-être des
tournois si c'était du 960 ce que je
trouve ça plus plus cool pour jouer en
amateur tu as moins le tout le travail
de préparation qui est chiant et
rébarbatif mais ça prend pas ça prend
pas du tout au niveau amateur je vois
bien votre au niveau de l'audience ou
même quand il est tournoi il y a peu de
gens que ça intéresse pour y participer
en tant que joueur donc
ça marche pas en fait
[Musique]
et tu as bien raison
de te poser des questions mon Fab mais
oui personne n'en a rien à [ __ ] de ce
jeu c'est non mais c'est la réalité
bah c'est ce que disait à rognan à
propos de ce jeu
c'est que c'est un jeu absolument
fantastique et hyper intéressant au
niveau professionnel mais trop difficile
au niveau amateur donc c'est un jeu qui
prendra jamais alors qu'on soit c'est
plus intéressant
dans son club il faut une soirée de 960
tous les ans
et c'était hier celle de cette année
mais oui bien sûr c'est
ah ouais puis tu as aucune hype tu as
aucune histoire
à propos du jeu là le même le
championnat du monde du jeu il est plus
que bizarre
en soi parce que
je crois que tu as eu 4 joueurs qui sont
qualifiés via Internet
et trois qualifiés d'office enfin je
veux dire c'est pas un championnat du
monde quoi non non mais c'est pas je
veux dire
ça le nom de championnat du monde mais
en soi
oui enfin nous aussi on peut en créer un
on va appeler Championnat du Monde et
puis voilà eh mais t'es pas la fille
on va appeler champion du monde des
chèques en finale
puis voilà puis on fera qui on fera ça
c'est un peu dommage parce que comme on
le disait pour les pros en tout cas
c'est un beau jeu qui mériterait d'être
un peu plus mis en valeur surtout vu la
quantité de tournoi quand même
inutile au cours de la saison il y
aurait un
moyen de
que ce jeu et une place un peu plus
importante au cours de la saison
mais malheureusement il a du mal à
trouver sa place
qui sait pas un beau jeu pour les pros
je connais pas mal de gens qui aiment
bien
il y a pas mal de joueurs qui aiment
les von a l'air d'être très heureux
ouais les vanille il aime bien
[Musique]
bon moi j'aime bien mais bon
parce que tu penses qu'il va tenter tu
penses qu'il peut tenter un D6 pour
essayer de battre qui aura lieu trois
tours c'est 5 genre le piège le plus éco
plus du monde
bah écoute il tout cas il a poussé son
pion il va peut-être pas si simple à
gagner par contre est-ce que j'adore
c'est que j'ai demandé à Vlad il y a
peut-être deux trois ans live si les
1960 il pensait que serait bien qu'il y
ait plus de tournant il m'a dit oui
j'adore et je vais demander à Vlad et tu
aimes bien le jeu
non j'ai est-ce que tu as raison tu
joues bien il m'a dit j'ai jamais joué
une partie
assez magnifique lovelade comme toujours
je suis d'accord
j'aurais probablement pas toute l'année
mais il y aura trois quatre temps dans
l'année je serais content
en fait c'est surtout bien pour les
joueurs de mon règne en vrai de vrai
[Musique]
en dernier mais il y avait pendant la
journée de repos de l'Open un tournoi
960 bah je suis allé le jouer j'étais
très heureux quoi donc il aurait fait un
semi rapide
normal Blitz A4 aussi beau jeu
je crois qu'on était catastrophique
quand on a jamais est-ce que c'est si
simple à gagner ça le truc qui est
intéressant 960 c'est que tu as souvent
aussi des finales avec des rapports
matériels c'est de depuis que je regarde
là
non mais genre tu as des rapports
matériels les positions que tu vois pas
trop est-ce que tu vois souvent au vrai
échec des et eux
en fait tu te retrouves avec des
structures de pions que tu peux pas
avoir normalement
mais non je sais pas à quel point c'est
simple de gagner ça je suis pas
convaincu parce que c'est pas comme dans
la partie de Magnus en fait où tu vas
avoir à qui tu vas partir et qui va être
hyper relou
ça me paraît pas si simple
je sais pas en fait très vite la
décision d'envoyer B pour échanger cela
dit tu vois je sais pas comment on
allait s'occuper de G parce que le
cavalier pour l'attaquer mais les
doubler c'est toi le défendre menace ce
matin
pense que la prépa c'est la profondeur
des échecs d'autres pensent différemment
après ouais non mais les prépas et la
théorie c'est intéressant après là le
problème que je trouve moi après la
théorie aujourd'hui c'est que c'est plus
des concepts que trouve des des humains
qui analyseraient les positions et qui
trouveraient des nouveaux concepts et
tout et ça c'est hyper intéressant c'est
génial là maintenant aujourd'hui c'est
plus des algorithmes qui cherchent et
qui trouve donc au bout d'un moment ça
perd un peu le le côté quasiment envie
de dire même scientifique du délire
je pense qu'il va faire tour quatre F7
3C 7 et D6 ou ça et des six et attendre
non
ouais bah du coup il va se prendre les
avancées de DA mais il va avoir les
échecs après si dès avance l'aurore à
plus de cachette je pense ça doit être
nul
intuitivement je dirais nul
bon je sais pas moi
je pense ça doit gagner pour les blancs
mais déjà je sais pas comment et
que par contre c'est pas simple mais
mais je suis pas trop sûr de ce que je
raconte
attention quand même parce que là il
menace tout premier
en fait c'est pas scientifique en mode
c'est des gens qui sont assis qui
réfléchissent comme des malades pour
trouver des choses c'est scientifique en
mode tu cliques sur un bouton et ça se
fait tout seul
en fait ouais c'est plus un jeu quoi
tu ne joues plus quoi tu répètes
dans quelques sortes un petit
restaurateur
c'est plus du tout clair Fab il s'est
passé quoi ici
ok bon ça se passe bien
très bien c'était plus 6 bim
S
[Musique]
c'est une bonne gueule pour les bananes
pour les Noirs parce que fouet fait un
tour point
FR3 roi G1 du coup seul coup pour
protéger H2 et pas se prendre les pions
dame G4 H1 H3
et là le problème et pourquoi ça gagne
pas c'est à cause de dame B83 F7 tours
roi G6 tu te fais tu te fais contrer
si une époque trouve ça peut devenir
chaud il y a 4 minutes 40 contre CAC 40
et de l'autre côté le problème c'est
qu'il faut faire c'est tu fais quoi
sinon en fait le bol de népot c'est que
la fin les bons coups c'est complètement
c'est ta seule chance qui est quelque
chose mais après il faut encore trouver
[Musique]
on reste un peu côté Magnus
bah comme tu veux ça a l'air d'être le
moment important Fab du de la partie là
c'est un moment décisif parce que si il
trouve pas et qu'il envoie un fou
français 6 ou un truc comme ça un peu
désespéré il va perdre
il lui reste 4 minutes ils ont dépassé
le 30e cool et deux hommes ils ont
récupéré les les 5 minutes de bonus
ça me fait penser vraiment les cinq
vidéos x comme dans Sonic tu sais quand
elle est les niveaux sous l'eau le
checkpoint
tu respires un petit peu tu ressembles
mais il faut trop dépêcher parce que le
temps passe vite après
pour lui trois minutes 30 c'est une
éternité
surtout pour Yann mais il a moins de
temps que Magnus dans cette partie
maintenant alors qu'il avait commencé
sur les chapeaux de roue il avait pris
l'étoile dans Mario et il courait comme
un fou furieux
un Magnus qui se recoiffe rapidement
pas l'air d'être très bien coiffé Magnus
attention
il n'y a que fou F1
et que la variante qu'on vous a montré
qui tient normalement il va la trouver
par élimination après je sais pas enfin
ça m'a l'air quand même dur à jouer
enfin pas s'il y a pas à la fin ça mais
peut-être que les noirs sont pas obligés
de te laisser le perpète ils peuvent
jouer avec la qualité de moi et le roi
un peu faible et c'est très probablement
ce qui va se passer ça reste mieux pour
les Noirs mais t'as pas perdu quoi non
exactement
si tu chopes le pion a ou quoi peut-être
dans les parties j'aime bien regarder
les dynamiques aussi c'est enfin faut
voir d'où tu viens
il a faim il est en train de le faire il
est en train de le faire mais on a on a
un petit retard évidemment sur sur les
péchés
quand même d'avoir un petit décalage
et côté Naka on en profite peut-être
bon position
tortue côté
côté qui doit attendre la poussée des
pions pour aller mettre un contre est-ce
que on peut pas essayer de monter le roi
vers C4 pour déjà avoir eu 4 5 160
d'échec et après on réfléchit quand on
fait aussi c'est pour casser on peut Fab
on peut le faire on verra mais ça ça
cette partie va durer plus longtemps
c'est les salaires d'être décisif là
dans la partie de Magnus mais il y a un
problème évidemment de retransmission
qui nous qui nous empêche Fab de suivre
cette partie de vibrer ouais de vibrer
exactement
et là ça doit vibrer un côté Magnus
aussi pour avoir les coups
complexe un complexe complexe alors
est-ce que j'ai une caméra
sur la caméra
sur l'échiquier qui nous permet
actuellement d'avoir la position et une
dame G4 échecs
qui s'est décalé ça a été vu par Magnus
peut-être le H3 dame B8 maintenant plus
trois minutes les secondes non 3,50 pour
Magnus les secondes ses graines alors
qu'on a à la position maintenant sur
l'échiquier qui est revenu n'est pas
dubitatif
il doit se dire j'ai du bol quand même
j'ai du bol et le bol
mais tu as envie de le faire
oui mais si tu vois qui a perpète
si tu vois
mais tu vois peut-être H3 dame B8 Roy F7
tours F1 cavalier F5
mesdames
est-ce que tu le vois
si tu le vois tu le vois mais si tu le
vois pas tu fais comment
tu es pas bien
on va voir s'il le voit Magnus
je remets la cam sur l'échiquier en
grand pour qu'on puisse voir les
secondes s'égrainer
de 50 pour les deux ça prend des pions
dans les mains attention quand même
c'est pas
il y a plus de 5 minutes mais ils ont
des 30 secondes il y a des secondes il y
a des secondes il y a des secondes
tension le pion quand même à ne prendre
que dans la main
donc quand même faudrait pas qu'il
repartent avec
il le fait tourner en tout cas pour le
moment non c'était un cheval plus que de
30 oh il doit pas être bien la Magnus il
sait qu'il a raté un truc très facile il
peut encore conclure mais c'est plus si
simple Fab
c'est un cheval c'est un cheval
exactement
tu tombes beaucoup plus vite
le fait de tourner ouais il a remis à
l'écurie il leur prend
donc en fait il faudra anticiper par
WhatsApp 3G7 aller se cacher en amont
mais bon moi j'aurais peur un rêve 7
tours
il reprend ce satané cheval entre les
mains
mais laisse ce cheval tranquille il est
en train de bouger le cheval il envoie
cavalier ou quoi trop
il a envoyé le cavalier en E4
OK
qui est très logique mais le cavalier
rejoint un peu moins l'attaque
mais ok au moins il a trouvé un truc
pour éviter les perpettes et de jeux
contre le roi adverse faible ce qui
voilà il menace maintenant non
de faire une idée comme ça ou tirer tu
passerais par derrière pour aller
chercher quelque chose non
plus de deux minutes pour Yann aussi les
deux hommes qui sont mal au temps
il a fait d'un B8 en premier tour F1
échec ça s'est joué cavalier F6 il
couvre
mais il a plus de menaces directes
avec la dame
[Musique]
bon bien en même temps il peut faire
d'un F5 il peut faire de la mèche 7 tu
as raison près d'un hêtre 6 je peux
surprendre trop de suite
[Musique]
F6 mais bon là ça a pas l'air de marcher
donc clairement avec les Blancs il
serait ravi d'échanger les dames
salut sécuriserait gravement son roi il
a s'occuper du pion a qui est passé mais
qui a plus personne pour le défendre
donc
ouais les pots tout ce qui a cherché à
faire c'est vite échanger les lames si
il peut
et sur H3 il doit vouloir faire un truc
comme tout rêve 2
et d'un F5
ou Détroit et dame g mais bon
là il y a des coûts qui sont joués
il a envoyé le pion à 3
comment est-ce qu'on fait dans F5
peut-être
quand même dame
on peut en avoir après ouais plus qu'une
façon d'un F5 tu as l'air d'être obligé
tu dois faire sinon tu te fais rouler
dessus il va te faire un don
[Musique]
ça y est il envoie
l'ordi dit sur le coup d'un H5 c'est pas
un coup facile hein
et après j'aurais réfléchi
c'est trop logique d'aller prendre des
deux dommage 5 c'est bizarre
il le fait
de quoi
en fait il y a pas de dommage 7 il y a
pas de dommage 3 il y a rien
je peux pas faire
de la part de Magnus
3 peut-être et tu reviens
je pense c'est ouais c'est bien qu'il y
ait plus d'amener quand même qui rode
parce que tu as un coup comme damasin
qu'on serait content de le faire mais
pas là quoi mais
il a remis la tour en F1
ah mais tu as aussi au 4 5 tu peux
partir
ah oui parce qu'en fait les noirs n'ont
plus de menace après tour Eiffel la dame
il sécurise tout mais en fait tu as eu 4
5 en piston
qui part
c'est loin d'être clair
ça parlait c'est pas con ça serait faim
il a joué des signes Cook 4
et surtout un il veut quoi
c'est complexe c'est hyper compliqué
c'est compliqué torrent
absolument rien à [ __ ]
un peu tout
c'est pas le mot
des deux ou tu laissais ta mâche 7 et
sur quatre
il a fait dans
ah c'est bien
alors après le roi repart de l'autre
côté et chaque quand même non
échec quand même
des trois et puis
et puis il y a de Pantin qui a fait
super chier le centre
mais bon parce que c'est gagnant je sais
pas mais
dans la pratique c'est hyper dur à jouer
et surtout tu as le pion a que tu as
toujours pas réussi à supprimer
dame 5
ouais il veut il veut lui ramener le roi
sur la colonne B pour lui planter un
tour bien échec
OK
mais il y a peut-être du E6 du coup
qui a réussi à cacher le roi des 8 et il
envoie à de
mesdames G2 c'est pas un coup
il reste plus que 15 secondes Adam j'ai
deux salaires forts de l'ordi c'est
jouer pariane dame prend des trois des
tours
et tout mais bon
une fois que tu prends un doute aller
tour à huile genre ça sert à rien du bon
en fait tu peux tu recommences à
t'activer parce que tu as supprimé au
Dambert échec ouais ça ça joue que sur
la cam maintenant Fab ok je vois plus
pour avoir les coups bah ouais mais tu
vas le voir immédiatement
oh c'est chaud dame B2
il commence à s'occupe du poteau là-bas
est-ce qu'on peut s'en occuper comme ça
il va il va faire un chantage à
l'échange
attention il y a peut-être un rebond
possible pour avoir du dame F3 ou dame
ou dame 4 échec plus que 6 secondes pour
Magnus attention 4 3 c'est changer
dedans
cavalier C3 est-ce que le roi revient oh
il envoie les pions c'est bien joué le
C5
tu dois
ouais il faut ramener le roi
il te fait chier en fait
mais peut-être tu laisses et tu ramènes
le rond des deux et des quatre rois E1
puis on prend puis on prend puis on
prend
le 5
e
il est pas en retard
ce qui serait pas en retard
il est important mais bon
tu dois c'est dur quoi
tu es dans la merde
[Musique]
je crois que tu es complètement foutu en
fait ah oui non mais c'est hyper bien
joué là ce qu'il a fait parce que sur B2
maintenant c'est hyper bien joué
en fait j'imagine
âge contre j'ai que tu prends des 4
c'est nul avec le cavalier en C3 et le
pion à deux c'est nul c'est une
forteresse enfin tu te fais pas tes
ouais je connais je me suis déjà pris ne
pense pas que je suis fort
je me suis déjà pris la couille
ça qui lui met le cavalier là
c'est chaud ouais ouais non avec le
cavalier C3 c'est un cas spécial
il va faire
qui arrive ouais mais attends il va
acheter 4 D2 il lui manque un temps
ah c'est terrible s'il avait eu le temps
d'échanger
il lui manque un thème
on va vite vite vite vite
ok
déjà terminé en réalité le temps de la
cloche
comment il a gagné
les pions il a bouffé un truc
il a bouffé tout en fait
[Rires]
quelle partie
mon Fab
attend
il a il a peut-être pas fait le truc le
plus simple pour gagner mais là à la fin
quand il est plus de temps il a bien
trouvé la finale là il a vachement bien
joué
avec le roi cavalier pion tu connaissais
pas ce petit truc qui est C3
c'est logique
tour est fin roi E3 H4 puis on prend
tour H1 allez en fait fallait le faire
comme ça
en fait ça tu fais ça tu fais ça et ça
c'est nul
qu'il fallait le truc dans lequel il
fallait rentrer c'est une forteresse
on arrive pas avec avec les Noirs à
décaler le cheval
tu peux mais là avec quelques secondes à
la pendule qui pense pas trop
en fait c'est pas
tu dis oui j'ai pas joué une fille avec
un pion et un qui avait demandé
est-ce que vous pensez faire des
analyses dans son sens sur la chaîne
pour voir si ça prend alors on l'a déjà
fait ça prend pas du tout mais on le
refera peut-être là avec le Championnat
du Monde oh on peut peut-être faire
juste une vidéo à titre informatif dire
un tel et a été sacré moi je dis patata
bon voilà mais puis bah montrer une
partie mais à mon avis
non les les gens sont trop intéressés
par par leurs ouvertures
qui connaissent pas qui connaissent pas
donc là il y a une petite pause
et après ça repart en fait ça annoncé le
à quelle heure ça rejoue ou
[Musique]
alors ouais je crois que c'est c'est
très très vite après genre et demi ou
peut-être même
en application avec chaise comme pour
avoir la position non non ça c'est même
avant
je peux je peux te je peux te dire les
horaires mais ça repart relativement
rapidement
c'est entre la en fait comme il change
de position c'est après qu'il y a une
pause plus importante entre la 3 et la
entre la 2 et la 3
parce qu'ils vont jouer une autre
position après
c'était annoncé à 15 tu vois c'est entre
la une et la 2 il y a il y a très très
peu de pause il est déjà 15 en fait oui
oui mais ça va repartir
[Musique]
quasiment immédiatement après
tu as le temps juste qui met en place à
mon avis à 20 c'est reparti
et après il y aura une un vrai quart
d'heure ou une vraie 20 minutes de pause
parce que
on change de position et qu'ils ont un
quart d'heure pour l'étudier
à mars et ça repart
donc finalement il y a une victoire avec
les Noirs Magnus et une victoire avec
les Blancs et carreaux
tous les deux quasiment tuer le match
oui d'ailleurs
ils vont pas 4 parties pour faire quatre
parties si jamais non
je pense que si quand même
[Rires]
bien sûr ça serait dommage de pas les
faire ou un truc comme ça
dans une pièce où ils n'ont pas le droit
d'utiliser d'ordinateur
donc c'est juste 15 minutes comme ça
pour s'imprégner de la position et un
peu raccourcir la cadence pour que les
sinon les premiers coups seraient trop
loin à jouer déjà là que l'ouverture
prend du temps mais laisse un peu de
temps off
live aux joueurs pour qu'ils puissent
démarrer la partie et on voit qu'il
commence de toute façon à beaucoup
réfléchir dès le deuxième troisième coup
enfin beaucoup ils sont quand même très
limités dans le temps mais
est-ce que est-ce que tu as les horaires
du championnat de France de coinche
enfin à Cannes
alors j'ai pas les horaires du tout mais
c'est en soirée en fait je crois que
stunt il hésite entre le tournoi des
chèques et le tournoi de coin cheval
dernièrement ah normalement il y a pas
d'hésitation c'est quoi un chat tous les
jours non
mais limite tu pourrais faire les deux
mais tu es pas sûr enfin bon vaut mieux
que tu concentres sur la coinche
mais bon est-ce que tu as un bon
partenaire toi est-ce que tu as ton
partenaire ou pas déjà pour la coinche
moi je sais pas si je joue en fait
tu vas peut-être pas le faire mais en
fait le problème c'est que je suis censé
jouer le week-end donc je peux jouer les
cahiers il fait bon c'est contre se
qualifier pour pas jouer la finale tu
peux pas annuler la Bundes pour la
coinche
bah en fait le problème c'est que Bundes
bon tu vois je suis plus trop dans les 8
titulaires quoi et on propose de jouer
parce que parce qu'il y a des gens qui
peuvent pas c'est ça je sais pas trop
pourquoi mais toi je peux pas trop faire
un film bouche pas sinon je joue plus
quoi c'est pas grave non plus mais
en plus je crois qu'ils ont fait exprès
de chercher une date où je pouvais enfin
que c'était pas trop relou
ouais mais ça te fait rater la fin
tu es quand même
j'ai pas vraiment en fait d'entraînement
il nous a fait un très long mail
oui il voulait essayer de parler de
défauts pour faire pour faire les appels
c'est intéressant
et il faudrait qu'on tente de mettre en
pratique parce que bon
tout ce qui est théorique comme ça en
fait ça a l'air bien marcher comme ça
mais il faut voir confronter faudrait
qu'on fasse un petit stage de coin chez
qu'on joue une petite dizaine d'heures
au moins sur le week end
et voir ce que ça donne
pour les prochains championnats
[Musique]
spécialement travaillé depuis la
dernière fois que j'ai joué alors
j'avais acheté des livres j'ai lu mais
Rémi mon équipe c'est de l'époque je les
ai donné je suis pas sûr que les élus
quoi donc toute façon faudrait qu'on
travaille si on veut les jouer comme ça
non ouais mais il est quand même
intéressant
je sais pas si la touche c'était son
discipline de prédilection je le sens
plus en mêler quand même
non tu le sens pas plus dans la mêlée
tout le monde en fait ce truc qui sert à
rien en fait je te donne moi le ballon
[Musique]
en fait ça devrait faire des coups
francs je pense c'est juste tu prends la
balle tu cours quoi
pour les joueurs
mais bon je sais pas c'est bon les
endroits ils appellent pas tous de la
même manière moi j'appelle ça la coinche
mais chez nous on appelle ça la contrée
[Musique]
chez nous on appelle ça la contrée
non mais je sais pas pourquoi on a
décidé que ça allait être le jeu le plus
compliqué et qu'on se dit tout est con
en fait non quoi
avec Stan dès qu'il y avait des gens
intellectuels on suit
le jeu de mémoire on se rappelle jamais
de rien juste on suit les autres en fait
voilà donc du coup oui il y a pas
d'annonce quoi
il n'y a pas d'annonce
bataille a pas les tiers les carrés les
conneries les trucs ça va rien
c'est tout on va évidemment tu fais les
annonces enfin les contrats quoi les
enchères on va dire mais
c'est tout j'avais pas capté il y a
cafetière dans le fond du truc c'est
magnifique en fait et les petites
bouteilles d'eau exceptionnel
c'est un peu comme le tarot non pas du
tout rien à voir
si tu veux dire un peu de loin ouais
enfin mais bon il y a des cartes dans
les deux jeux si tu veux
autant jouer au bridge car la belote
bridge super intéressant Mathieu s'il
est mis ouais je sais que c'est
intéressant c'est trop en fait
non c'est cool mais du coup Mathieu en
fait il a une appli où il y a des sortes
de petits problèmes à faire comme aux
échecs tu vois et où genre tu vois cinq
cartes et on te dit tu vas faire quatre
plis à tous et ça où il y a pas d'atouts
etc et comment tu joues et c'est genre
une étude c'est taquet de manière de
jouer il faut forcer le jeu quoi
et ok donc ça bon ça je fais aller
ailleurs
mais le truc c'est que c'est à part ça
je sais même pas les règles je sais pas
comment tu annonce je sais pas combien
tu as de cartes au début enfin je sais
rien
mais c'est quoi ce truc de mémoire dans
le guide parce que c'est pas juste des
maps ou tu te sautes des barres dans la
tranche normalement c'est que ça mais
ils ont décidé de mettre un jeu ou tu as
des trucs qui s'affiche à l'écran et tu
dois te rappeler sur quelqu'un de les
trucs qui étaient bon nous hier on a
fait avec Stone un moment donné il y
avait deux trucs à se rappeler il y
avait deux schémas donc il y avait
c'était genre une chaussure ou une fusée
et moi je dis à stunt sur la fusée donc
du coup Stone va sur la chaussure 10
secondes après il me dit merde je sais
plus sur quoi je suis
moi non plus je savais plus enfin je
vais enfin je sais pas moi j'ai une
fusée je sais plus ce qu'il y a d'autre
en fait j'étais
donc imagine quand il y avait quatre
cinq trucs à se rappeler on n'était pas
bien
du coup en fait un moment donné il s'est
mis sur un truc il m'a dit je sais que
c'est là moi j'ai suivi d'autres mecs je
lui dis non enfin reste sur ton truc
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je suis les autres
et ils avaient raison les autres bah là
on a eu du bol mais sur le dernier en
fait tout le monde allait sur un truc
c'était pas le bon mais on a eu de la
chance comme tout le monde s'est planté
on s'est quand même qualifié
mais bon enfin on regarde absolument pas
ce qui se passe
mais c'est un beau jeu
et
je suis attentivement pendant
que j'ai là j'aurais peut-être pu passer
de toi là si c'était maintenant
c'est un peu long là non c'est beaucoup
trop longs
par contre quand on arrive dans la
finale de Fall Guy c'est vrai qu'on a un
gros un gros ratio de victoire
on a les nerfs solides
parce qu'après il y a encore une pause
d'une demi-heure machin enfin c'est bon
jouer quoi enfin
jouer messieurs bah faudrait victoire de
mon accueil histoire de Magnus et
revictor de la cave
je sais pas comment ils s'en sortent
pour toujours faire des trucs vraiment
très longs
même quand c'est rapide c'est long en
fait
et puis de son épouse
je pense
je sais pas ouais je sais pas comment
ils font ça
si c'est pas chiant ça va pas ouais j'ai
pas parce qu'en fait les parties sont
longues quoi donc et des charges
non mais là quand on réfléchit quand
même commencé déjà 1h30 on est à peine
au quart du truc enfin
de base tu me dirais qu'un match de fin
même le tennis de foot quoi alors tu as
rien eu quoi
même le tennis si tu me disais à chaque
fois avant le match que ça va durer 6h
je regarderai jamais en fait
pour voir quand ça compte quoi
mais c'est pas la même position
il a plu
voilà moi
ce qui va refaire ce qui va faire G5
comme comme
des pots en fait c'est la théorie de la
position
c'est comme si c'était c'est pas si con
c'était horrible quoi
[Musique]
il y a un gars qui est venu à jouer le
premier coup ils l'ont applaudi ils
étaient tous très moi aussi
c'est bien et probablement que la
personne en question doit être connue
après bizarre de faire un coup d'envoi
fictif à toutes les parties en soi je
trouve
oui oui normalement la première
moi je te torcherai ça chaque jour de
service avec un service quoi avec nous
on serait déjà parti 4 là ce serait déjà
en train de ranger nous en fait on
serait déjà en train de ranger la
cafetière
ce qui est vrai avec des pauses c'est
quoi qui Enzo il joue tempo en fait mais
là laissez le fou prend B3 c'est quand
même une grosse erreur c'était quand
même pas très difficile dans la première
avec nous ce serait en belette ouais oh
bah oui nous c'est
ça serait bien
[Musique]
ouais
en fait tu perdrais 3 minutes
quoi
on enlève on enlève du temps à la
pendule
en tout cas c'est logique ce qui fait
alors je sais pas s'il va faire c'est 6
ou cahier des 6 pour défendre le pion B7
ou très moche des cinq mais qui est
peut-être jouable
après c'est les mais bon tu prends du tu
prends de l'espace tu prends des cases
j'aurais jamais fait mais je serai pas
non plus mais
compliqué en tout cas à ce jeu
tu es un peu déçu qu'on est deux fois le
même début quasiment
il a fait C6 donc il semble le plus
logique mais
parce qu'en fait au premier coup après
si on revient la position tu aurais pu
commencer aussi par un coup comme D4 en
réalité bah c'est ça même eux 4
pourquoi pas
tant pis
c'est bien
et je crois qu'il y a des positions qui
sont plus belles que d'autres pour les
départs je leur parle là où tu as plus
de
punch
B3
c'est pas trop un coup qui me semble
des systèmes et je sais pas quoi enfin
pourquoi pas mais pourquoi
si vite
il y a tellement d'autres couples
mais je crois qu'il s'en fout royalement
en fait c'est pas possible on remarque
sa manière de jouer si je joue tout le
temps comme ça mais c'est incroyable
ouais mais là c'est
pas bien jouer en faisant ça en fait
enfin encore moins le jeu là c'est trop
[Musique]
je sais pas tu peux manger 4 essayer de
faire le 5 à développer tes pièces
est-ce que je fais peut-être ou pas où
est-ce que je vais enfin [ __ ] il y a
trop de questions à se poser
et il en a rien à [ __ ]
[Musique]
je prends de l'espace et puis voilà
moi c'est je comprends pas trop ce
comment il veut cavalier j'ai
l'impression qu'il bouge plus en fait
dans la gueule il bouge plus d'ailleurs
du coup la tour bouge pas du coup le roi
ça a l'air kata
non mais en fait avec les Blancs si on
parle un peu normalement
je ferais bien G5 j'essaierai d'échanger
toutes les cases noires
et puis je suis mieux avec mon fou et
une merde et je te fais H4 je vais fixé
la structure et je fais des choses quoi
bon après est-ce que bon ce qu'on a le
temps de mettre tout ça en place mais je
vois mal les Noirs ce qu'ils font alors
peut-être histoire G5 va te faire E5
mais
un petit ou trois qui va je pense qu'il
va faire 5 clairement moi c'est le coup
qu'elle je pensais sur G5
tu dois prendre prendre et
ok là c'est un coup important mais j'ai
du mal à comprendre la suite
on se ressort la tête de l'eau là on va
verser 5 ou je sais pas
alors question je pense pas que tu es le
droit de ok sur MD2 fou C5
donc c'est chiant
mais j'ai 5 ça va faire mal ouais
mais voilà gaffe de tout à l'heure elle
est incroyable quand même juste ça ils
en reparle dans le chat et ouais parce
que c'était vraiment évident qu'il
voulait faire [ __ ] en B3 il a juste
oublié en fait c'est pas possible
autrement non non mais il l'a vu tu fais
pas fou il fait il fait il a fait quoi
cet effet
la Casa quoi donc il a vu mais il a pas
vu ton frère par contre
mais je veux dire même l'autre ou t'as
pas ta première Fiat déjà elle
paraissait chiante par rapport au 4 qui
était cool du premier le centre et enfin
ça se voit pas de raison de
préférez ça bah
je sais pas étrange et est-ce que on
voit
il y a eu G5 et l'autre position on va
ajouter un œil j'ai l'impression que
l'autre match est potentiel va
potentiellement être plus serré quand
même ouh là
ah ouais c'est chaud
un truc comme ça
parce que tu arrives tranquille genre
qu'elle humain ça doit te faire des 5 et
complètement fraise peut-être qu'il est
perdu
[Musique]
ce match
on va dire Beck qu'on attendait vraiment
sur ces demi-finales qui déçoit un petit
peu Fab
mais peut-être qu'ils sont trop forts en
fait comme ça
ils sont avant tout ça fait vraiment une
différence énorme de classe
ça semble
ok alors est-ce qu'on peut faire le
petit fouet F23
[Musique]
j'aime bien
H4 et petit rock bizarrement H4 ouais de
toute façon j'ai envie de faire
mais en plus surtout que la colonache on
va peut-être pouvoir l'envahir si la
tour reste en butée là-bas
ça a l'air catastrophique pour les noirs
parce que il y a un truc stratégique qui
se met en place
un peu tu vois
OK
la raison des potes faire petit rock
après je pense pour essayer de vite vite
faire 5 en réalité je reviens
voilà ce qui est bien pour pour les
blancs c'est que sur cavaler à 8 B6 sur
encore le pion C6 en l'air
ça peut être important dans certaines
lignes
enfin c'est le meilleur mais
t'évite un peu le 5 tu développes ton
cavalier
c'est bien
pour préparer E5 et cavalier à 8 B6 ça
fait cavalier à 8 mais c'est la même
idée
bon peut-être laisser un petit B4 un
jour pour là je vois bien que c'est pas
une menace encore mais ça sera peut-être
un peu
après ça se voit que ça peut pas trop
aller pour les Noirs mais bon quand même
attention ça peut vite tourner c'est
parti
tu peux pas trop bouger la dame il faut
prendre des quatre peut-être trois
coups
d'épée dans l'eau
mais je veux dire combien on perdrait
pas la tour ça fait un peu pareil
quand même
non mais toi je t'ai pas trop sûr de moi
c'est peut-être un peu c'est juste ça te
rassure tu tiens tout mais bon comme lui
calcule quand même pas trop mal il peut
se permettre plus facilement des coups
comme ça
il a pas dû vouloir laisser
de 5
il y a pas tellement d'attaque sur le
roi noir non ou alors c'est très long à
mettre en place mais il faudrait triplé
sur la colonage c'est un peu trop long
mais ça pourra roder un jour dès que
c'est ça
c'est plus ou moins menace la tente on
va dire c'est protéger tout bêtement
c'est tout bêtement protégé on sait six
avec le foie H1
mais d'où l'idée de dame 8 en fait de
préparer un peu 5 et de protéger ses 6
ok je crois qu'il prépare petit rock
bête
non peut-être béga 4 on se fait une case
arrière
aussi pour aller dans ton idée tout à
l'heure ouais mais du coup tu es pas
moins bien que pour faire ça
j'ai envie de dire j'aurais préféré
madame g2-3 si c'était pour faire ça
je suis d'accord avec toi maintenant tu
es parti dans cette direction
en plus dans ce genre de structure c'est
bien enfin
on va peut-être cacher
je pense ça rentre dans le
ouais ça rentre dans la position
je vais essayer de faire baisser la case
des 5 mais pour le moment il est
toujours c'est 600 l'air
sans force de joueurs c'est un peu le
numéro 1 et contre le numéro de mondial
en quelque sorte
et dans l'autre partie juste furtif
mais je sais pas à quel point ça se
passe
en tout cas
qui fait mal d'entrée
des mieux d'avance quand même quasiment
pour pour nepo ça peut avoir une valeur
le truc c'est qu'il faut voir comment
avec les blancs peuvent stabiliser parce
que c'est une époque qui s'est levée
attends je vais allumer la lumière
en fait tu sens que tu es mieux à long
terme
clairement une évolution d'imposition
quoi le B4 le petit rock c'est un et tu
prépares B5 mais les Noirs ils vont
essayer de passer les SFR ça veut dire
que tu fais B4
un peu moins un moyen protégé donc tu as
raison il tombe B5 peut-être pour casser
et où kb6 c'est ou je sais pas quoi
enfin il va trouver
et donc je sais pas
du coup tu es obligé de très concret
quoi enfin tu peux pas juste faire tes
petits coups et
et donc je sais pas ouais B4
on peut se bouger les pièces pour
comprendre
je passe la tour et je reviens après et
je prépare 5
c'est compliqué hein
bon ça au moins la chanson qu'on a à peu
près bien mis les pièces avec les Blancs
mais c'est un peu un ressort la position
noire quand il se quand il se détend il
peut te exploser à la tronche passer une
tronche de hollandaise un peu
ouais
mais de hollandaise bizarre quand même
G5
[Musique]
par rapport
on a peut-être qu'un truc qui marchait
mal sur B4 c'était moins solide un truc
qui lui plaisait pas
la manœuvre de l'ordi est magnifique
pour les Noirs cavaliers eux aussi
touche le pion E3 cavalier D8 sur
portail ok B4 maintenant j'ai compris le
troisième coup sans le voir et date et
là tu réussis à faire 5 dans de bonnes
conditions
et ça c'est vraiment dangereux pour ça
peut ressembler aussi à des Slaves même
si elle pion des 6 mais tu sais quand on
essaye de t'enfermer là il t'envoie le 5
et genre pour illustrer si on échange
tout en E5 en fait c'est position là
c'est des vrais ressorts
mais ouais si une époque trouve ce plan
là il peut gagner la partie mais il est
très difficile cavalue aussi c'est tout
sur tempo qui avait lieu aussi touche le
pion cavalier D8 protège donc menace B6
et cavalier F7 pour E5
en fait une fois que tu l'as vu c'est
hyper logique
ça paraît même facile mais bon
c'est toujours ça en fait
[Musique]
en tout cas les Noirs il faut qu'ils
arrivent à s'activer quoi c'est clair
qu'ils ont pas le choix parce que tu
t'es trop mal
tu laisses trois quatre coups de
consolidation au blanc c'est fini en
fait
complètement
donc il faut faire
et là pour l'instant on n'arrive pas
donc c'est vrai que de ramener un
cavalier pour t'aider à le faire c'est
pas logique et quasi 7 c'est la seule
dispo donc quand tu as parlé comme ça
dans ta tête tu trouves mais le problème
c'est que c'est dur
c'est très dur
ça peut ça peut être trouvé mais
tu vois là c'est vraiment pour moi
typiquement le truc ça peut trouver ça
peut ne pas trouver je sais pas comment
ouais
c'est pas facile en fait c'est City
pense si tu réussis à y penser ça
devient évident mais ça peut rester dans
la zone d'ombre tu vois dans quel sens
je souhaite
amener le débat
bon après
il y a un autre coup je jouable
je sais pas qui fait des bas c'est des
cinq
c'est en fait de base ce qu'on veut
faire c'est c'est 5 sauf qu'on parle
cavalier
parce que des 5 bloc C6 mais les blancs
vous pouvez faire c'est 5 tu vois les
gens c'est cool pour faire le temps
ferme tout quoi et tu es bien avec les
blancs mais bon sauf que tu perds une
pièce quoi donc c'est plus si bien mais
qui se répand à 5 on serait très heureux
avec les Blancs et donc des cinq bah tu
dois plus ou moins le prendre j'imagine
et maintenant qui arrive en dessin c'est
l'autre qui arrive en dessin
ok tu fais des trousses chez toi chacun
a ses cases en fait je veux dire mais
[Musique]
c'est une option
de faire des
c'est pas absurde
mais le cavalier juste
il veut cavalier je ne sais où
découverte
il y avait aussi sa priori et sur B4 il
doit vouloir c'est 5 c'est ça
même pas
ce qu'il veut
c'est quand même logique
ça va être joué mais il doit y avoir une
idée mesdames c'est bizarre parce que la
dame en fait elle repart
ou alors il veut 5 ah il veut ça
ça
et en fait tu peux plus prendre enfin tu
peux peut-être prendre mais au pire tu
as peut-être prise et prise ici
tu commences même parfois aussi c'est
chèque histoire de gagner encore un
tempo et tu prends G5
ok c'est questionnable qui est mieux
j'en sais rien c'est très compliqué à
juger
ok
[Musique]
il veut marcher un truc très concret qui
a une sale gueule quoi donc
[Musique]
la seule chose qui peut faire sens c'est
de se mettre sur le la colonne D et le
et le
façon il faut prendre on va pas se
laisser faire le 4 enfin encore moins
avec une pièce en extraire des trois
mais
donc
c'est quasiment faire forcer
puis je sais pas
je préfère les blancs quand même parce
que tu arrives pas bien à organiser les
chevaux mais après si tu réussis à vite
vite taper ces quatre
ça a été joué 5 tu as réussi à trouver
les plans quand même leur dit à part
mais
on trouve les idées
puis on prend puis on prend la prise V
on va voir bon au moins bon en tout cas
il a cherché un truc pour activer la
position
après le cavalier e6d8 F7 il était dur à
voir oui mais c'était clairement
honnêtement plus fort
je sais pas à quel point c'est dur ou
pas dur oui enfin si c'est très dur
c'est sûr que c'est très dur
et qu'est-ce qui se passe du côté de
népot mais je pense que ça va être
terrible en fait de Naka ouais je pense
avec le terrible la position
qui va qui va résulter
ça va pouvoir faire de zéro des deux
côtés
[Musique]
voilà c'est ça paraît vraiment bien
fais voir sur la caméra ouais
peut-être que le suspense n'est pas
présent pour ces demi-finales mais ça
nous promet une finale explosive
avoir ainsi Magnus une épaule lui encore
des petites chances nous dire Beck ça me
paraît ça me paraît trop
tiens Magnus en fait il a pris de f Il a
pas il est pas allé chercher le fou il a
pas voulu se prendre un échec
ouais c'est pas si clair encore quand
même
il fait H4 la dame qui va repartir
je trouve que la poêle la position là
elle peut encore se tourner
mais tu peux même gagner avec les Noirs
d'ailleurs
les blancs sont mieux mais ça reste du 3
résultats
il est pas bien le saumon nous dit pas
bien autant ouais mais
ça va lui suffire on voit la caméra
qu'il a fait un H4 H5 et ça donne envie
hein
en plus si tu veux transformer le truc
mais
c'est fou comment Magnus domine n'est
pas dans tous les formats en fait
tous les jeux il nous manque quelques
coups je vais mettre la caméra sur
l'échiquier
qu'on puisse les voir
parce que là ça clique
le mieux
[Musique]
si tu sais un peu en ressort mais le
problème c'est que là le ressort il a
l'air d'être pété
on est trop tiré dessus donc il a plus
de c'est un ressort de lit femme
c'est un ressort de lit
car il est ici soit il essaye de
mais
on a la position sur les
on va repasser en caméra
en caméra grand plan
après c'est typique le genre de position
où tu peux te tromper avec les Blancs
oui oui en fait tu sais j'ai une petite
règle pour moi c'est qu'en fait les fous
quand tu es rock opposé et tu as tes
fous proches de ton roi
c'est beaucoup mieux parce qu'ils
défendent ton roi et tape le roi adverse
alors que regarde les fous blancs ils
sont à l'envers du jeu en réalité ouais
donc c'est une petite règle que je me
suis inventé
quand tu es en roc opposé il faut avoir
les fous devant ton roi si tu peux
parce que du coup ils attaquent le roi
adverse une paire de cou quoi ah ils
font une pierre de cou et là les fous
blancs ils sont ils sont mal placés
tiens regarde imagine les fouilles genre
en B3 B2
cisailleurs là les fous sont quand même
Alain à l'envers donc ça peut jouer
créer ses propres principaux et c'est
mon principe en fait je me suis créé ce
principe pour moi-même et ça fonctionne
assez bien
après ça c'est un principe de merde il y
a que moi qui l'utilise et je suis
complètement nul mais non mais genre
c'est pratique quand même même bon
c'est pas mal quoi
c'est une certaine logique quand même
c'est un principe je t'envoie des
principes dans la gueule tu es là tu es
pas bien hein
non mais ouais enfin ça a pas l'air si
simple pour Magnus là
il suit complètement quoi tu as des fois
à l'envers
en plus il te gêne en H1 là
[Musique]
il est pas tôt
tu es complètement gagnant je pense
ouais mais bon tu connais pas les
principes donc bon tu devais faire petit
rockeur
il le comprend vraiment rien Fabien tu
sais mais dommage 3
non mais ça ça peut en plus 10 minutes
de d'écart quand même
moi il va avoir besoin de 1 2 3 coups de
préparation encore des géants
et si on se fait on se tortue
F7 tour des 8 on se barre quoi on se met
là quand fuite on est bien
et tout d'un coup
on reprend des trois d’apprendre B4 vous
prend tout d'un coup
la défauts sont pas mal en fin de
formation carapace aussi
c'est un peu des boucliers pour ton roi
quoi
si tu passes derrière les fous ils se
prennent les flèches dessus ils s'en
foutent quoi
les blancs
à vous de jouer il est pas très dur le
gars grosse gaffe qui a été 7 en fait
c'est le même truc à partir
tout de suite puis on prend cavalier
prend touche la dame
bouffe et tu prends B8 et c'est
exactement la même chose dans la partie
précédente la tour est deux pions compte
deux pièces
on sait pas trop mais
[Musique]
ça va pousser quoi un peu comme tout à
l'heure tu as encore des chances de la
tenir mais ouais
mais ça a été joué mais c'est fou
il en a absolument rien à [ __ ] il
clique juste
ah c'était en plus ce fou qui était mal
placé à l'envers du théorème
c'est dommage de perdre sur des gaffes
comme ça Fab ouais mais bon à jouer
tempo comme ça c'est obligé que ça
t'arrive
vu je l'avais pas vu
est confiant bon si il gagne celle-là de
0 c'est quoi ziplier
avec son ventre peut-être
de la chance quoi c'est de zéro
mais ce qui tourne mal pour des pauses
et que même quand par chance en fait
c'est pas si clair il
gaffe en fait
OK
je pense
c'est bien joué
peut-être qu'il avait ça en réalité
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'on est mauvaise
langue
quoi que il aurait joué à tempo aussi il
avait
et du coup le problème c'est quoi je
remets un petit coup d'ordi désolé les
amis c'est tout machin et si je fais
tour C8 ah c'est cavaliers
va me prendre dans ma chute
[Musique]
ok ouais
ça c'est extraordinaire quoi l'ordi te
fait qui 5 il t'attaque il défend il
attaque des trois il veut d'un poisson
F7 et il te refaites
dans ta gueule en fait
et tout d'un coup tu es mal
ton C8 Dame des cinq c'est jouer
et là faut qu'il trouve le théorème des
fous voici l'Alter est fou il va gagner
[ __ ] il va gagner il va pas perdre et
si tu fais tour C6 prix c'est ah oui tu
as pas fou F7 parce qu'il y a ça en
l'air
en vrai c'est trouvable
surtout que tu peux prendre prendre et
d'un mec si tu veux
ça doit aller incroyable il a raté ouais
enfin incroyable c'était pas facile tu
auras un pour cavalier 7 c'est le manque
de temps
finalement la stratégie de dépôt
fonctionne quoi
non mais c'est juste que c'est une
manière bizarre de jouer mais c'est vrai
que c'est tu mets en difficulté
l'adversaire parce qu'il doit réfléchir
pour réfuter tes conneries
et si là et si tu as la réfutation comme
là il faut prendre un C6 n'est pas aussi
fort que ce comté bah tu te retrouves
mal au temps et tu suis
ça fait partie des
candidats en réalité parce que de toute
façon tu dois défendre
et si tu fais dame F7 par exemple
ok facile
donc ça tu peux pas
roi F7 j'ai même pas envie de regarder
par principe
je probablement jusqu'à Vali F4
d'ailleurs
dame 7 tu peux pas il faut F7 ça va me
prendre des 7
donc pareil élimination tu arrives à te
repenser si tu as pensé 6 puisque la
tour protège le cavalier
et après qui va laisser 5 et 3 pour
pouvoir mettre le fond F7 qui soit plus
en prison et c'est assez logique
cette afficheur l'adversaire pour éviter
tes conneries je vais bientôt être
champion du monde ouais mais le truc
c'est qu'il faut pas faire trop de
conneries pour qu'elle soit dur à
réfuter
je débarque c'est quoi le bail entre
backendel mais en fait il y a pas de
paille pourquoi tout le monde c'est
peut-être le
45e message déjà Fab que je reçois
twitch et Twitter réunis
que que Maxime est plus entraîner
secondé par Baki est à tout le monde qui
dit c'est quoi le bail pourquoi il sait
pas ou quoi bah juste
c'est une séparation logique en réalité
c'est il y a rien de plus logique pas un
joueur qui joue moins bien depuis un an
et demi deux ans et qui change son coach
ça paraît
ça arrive tous les weekends dans Ligue 2
[Musique]
ça fait aussi du bien des fois de voir
quelqu'un d'autre juste pour avoir soit
d'autres idées un autre discours voilà
ça marchera mieux ça marchera moins bien
ça marchera pareil après dur à dire mais
tu essayes quelque chose
c'est l'addition de Maxime et très
logique et c'est tout à fait normal ça
fait quand même
bientôt une décennie qui travaille
ensemble
un bon moment c'est une très longue
période on en avait parlé aussi dans
notre vidéo de Maxime deuxième partie de
carrière qui qui débute et tout ça de
toutes ces choses là sur sur la chaîne
et
il y a une certaine logique dans la
décision de Maxime donc c'est trouver un
par un épaule toute la variante
des 6
[Musique]
mais il y a pas de
il y a pas de drama de clash où je ne
sais quoi c'est juste un truc
professionnel on va dire entre
guillemets quoi
rien de plus logique que ça alors
finalement
[Musique]
tout d'un coup
il menace peut-être des cavaliers F4
d'ailleurs avec des cavaliers de en
rebond des dames prend E5 alors il y
avait pas d'âme probablement coup
d'avant à cause de prise prise et tout
droit
il avait peut-être mais en soit j'ai
l'impression que tu as envie de garder
les dames avec le théorème quoi
ouais en plus toi
je sais pas trop ce que tu veux tourner
bon en tout cas je suis d'accord
des 5 6 machin qui t'arrive dessus tant
que tu as la dame qui passe au travail
c'est compliqué de pousser les pions
va travailler c'est mais vous en a déjà
parlé c'est très secret le monde des
seconds je pense que Maxime va essayer
de le révéler le plus tard possible
quoi ça sert de donner des informations
au
aux concurrents
s'il peut garder
Louise savoir quoi qu'il en soit parce
qu'on te voit
soit trop souvent à quelqu'un
s'organiser des trucs soit dans les
mêmes villes trop souvent et où
peut-être au style de jeu avec les
ouvertures ou quoi je sais pas mais
c'est vrai que si sur le coup tu as rien
besoin de dire ça rien de dire trop vite
Manon n'est pas dans le dans le secret
des dieux on sait pas très franchement
j'en sais pas si c'est des jeunes tu
vois ça pourrait être du parambulant par
exemple
déjà travaillé ensemble et tout ça
pourrait mais après ça je vois pas trop
comment
un petit sparring quelqu'un qui cherche
des idées mais pas assez rare en fait
quelqu'un comme qui pour encadrer et
diriger le truc par âme il a pas
l'expérience pour ça quand même non
il est souvent
c'est plus des bacs des casimes des gens
comme ça des vlades quoi enfin peut-être
c'est vlades
Magnus encore mon Fab il a raté fou pro
aussi
ça va craquer il va se prendre les fous
théorème aide oh bah il a encore des
choses à prendre Magnus c'est terminé à
dos ça va égaliser pour pour Yann ça
boit un petit peu d'eau bah oui là il
est très heureux regarde le petit
sourire en fait il est complètement nul
ma glouche comment j'ai perdu la
première contre un tel
regarde comment il est content il expose
son bide
et il fait mal
il a l'air heureux là non
il se barre
[Rires]
regarde le fou prend aussi quoi c'était
pas vu il est hyper énervé
là regarde ça il fait ses petits gestes
d'énervement
[Musique]
dès la sortie je quitte le tournoi après
cette défaite
il a l'air énervé là mais bon perdant le
truc qui était vraiment bien quoi
prix du fair-play
portant
ça
ce qui va nous dire je ne peux pas
parler sinon big travel serait beau que
la partie chaise pics for it self quoi
enfin
il est hyper énervé
ça va demander une inspection anale à la
sortie oh que oui
bah disons c'était un peu une balle de
match parce que c'est ça qui gagne
c'était terminé
[Musique]
mais tu as vu
en fait c'est beau maintenant tu as
donné des cours tes stages à parler du
théorème des fous très important
non mais ça marche vraiment cette
connerie non mais en fait j'ai jamais lu
donc effectivement mais ça
boule de sens vu comme ça
je te fais des mètres de Boden tiens
je n'ai jamais lu et c'est trop
compliqué
je suis avec dans le nombril
de Bollène
bonjour de rugby
du poil de la bête ils ont gagné ils ont
gagné le
victoire dico dans la deuxième juste
annonce ça donc le match est déjà plié
ils ont gagné finalement le fornication
mais on va aller recevoir on va aller
concasser mon Fab
j'ai l'impression que c'était à deux
doigts d'être en crise intégrale quoi
tu étais très énervé ah je suis énervé
ouais quand ils ont perdu des affaires
de l'Afrique du Sud
bah ouais mais bon ils ont un rugby
tellement restrictif
c'était horrible mais les blagues non
mais c'était frustrant parce que tu
sentais qu'il voulait jouer tu sais leur
jeu de passe dans la défense adverse
et il n'y arrivait pas et tu finis
tu sentais que c'était ça le rugby ça
sentait le rugby ce que faisait les
Blacks mais il n'arrivait pas à
à matérialiser leur action
alors que les les bots
[Musique]
passaient une passe en fait
faire une passe et courir et ils vont se
casser sur ta ligne il refont sans arrêt
et puis après c'est jouer au pied quand
ça avance pas ces chandelles enfin bon
c'est pas le beau et bichon pas
ok non bah c'est efficace après c'est
beau aussi les oppositions de style mais
bon c'est frustrant
est-ce que ça vaut le coup de changer de
second nom comme le ministre a un
répertoire restreint mais dans lequel il
est excellent ouais mais ça c'est trop
compliqué en fait on sait pas en fait
mais personne ne sait
bah en fait si il a de très bons
résultats ça aurait été une bonne idée
en fait enfin mais c'est dur de dire à
l'avance
en fait chaque choix que tu as fait tu
peux pas savoir l'avance pas que genre
même si je te parle de foot genre le
roman tout le monde se fout de sa gueule
parce qu'il a joué en 3 5 2 à Manchester
City même s'il avait gagné Paris avait
été éliminé et Machin je sais pas bon si
vous vous souvenez quoi mais ça se
trouve il mettait son son 4 3 3 et il
perdait oui il n'a jamais pensé à faire
l'effet de surprise doit Tati patata on
analyse toujours avec le prisme du
résultat en fait donc c'est une décision
bah elle a pas l'air absurde en soi ce
qu'elle est bonne ou est-ce qu'elle est
mauvaise après bon on verra bien après
le risque n'est pas énorme pour Maxime
en réalité
c'est que là tu étais en perte de
vitesse et que donc tu tentes un truc
pour réagir
une sorte d'électrochoc quoi
c'est un peu con parce que je gagne pas
de matériel opération
en réalité
mais là c'est peut-être chose non mais
c'est bête non
après tu peux changer comme ça ça va
très bien
ça marche tout le temps
de l'autre côté c'est
ça marche absolument tout le temps en
fait
[Musique]
ça change pas une équipe qui gagne c'est
déjà arrivé un des changements
d'entraîneur alors que l'équipe marchait
plus ou moins des fois ça marche quand
même
il a changé plein de fois
[Musique]
non mais je crois que c'était trop
pressé trop vite et que tu peux pas être
sur gagner en fait même avec l'Amérique
ils ont jamais Reut à un entraîneur de
ce calibre en réalité
non mais après franchement les mecs il
est très bon
vire il est moins emblématique on va
dire quand je dis mais peut-être qu'il
fera une carrière tout aussi bonne si on
en reparle dans 10-15 ans 20 ans
emblématique pour pour caler leur
vestiaire
il y a pas de problème
[Musique]
donc pour elle pas mal Emrys était bien
mais peut-être qu'emery c'était pas il
est mieux pour le niveau un peu en
dessous comme là ce qu'il a fait
régularial c'était beau
ils sont pas en dernier c'est pas la
même chose mais ouais peut-être que pour
gérer des stars c'est moi ça j'en sais
rien après faut peut-être qu'il y a peu
de chance mais même blanc c'était pas si
mal ce qui faisait en fait ils ont quand
même dégagé un peu comme une merde
franchement ça jouait pas mal au foot
donc je sais pas en fait mais là ça va
aussi mais bon ça va pas aller bien loin
non plus quoi
voilà pourquoi pas enfin en fait j'ai
l'impression que tu mettrais n'importe
qui c'est pas mal ça tu vas être
champion de France normalement et tu
passes toujours les poules donc après le
monde va-t-elle viendra plus tard dans
l'année
tu penses même nous si on est en train
du PSG on passe franchement même des
consignes
juste même c'était moi je me retrait et
que tu les laisses s'auto gérer enfin
pour décider ton trio d'attaquant ça a
l'air trop dur quand même
et puis
bon après je sais pas enfin
de toute façon tu as des adjoints tu as
des gens enfin oui je pense que même
nous on va faire des compos quoi
possible ça serait magnifique en fait
les deux cons le duo de l'entraîneur et
deux abruti finalement
[Musique]
pour dépôt non parce que regarde c'est
le roi blanc qui est faible
plus de pièces pour l'attaquer tu as les
fameux fous braquer
et tu as une pièce de plus pour
l'attaquer en plus ça me fait plaisir
que tu appelles les fameux fous déjà tu
les as déjà adoptés
dans les cours ça a été tout le temps
[Musique]
ils sont forts c'est fou
moi la vidéo que la table d'échec soit
si petite on est là pour
le top d'échec je pense
et on voit bien quand même
moi je sais pas trop quoi vous dire moi
je suis sur le cheescom de toute façon
en général pour commenter donc je vois
même pas ce que vous voyez
tout à l'heure là je vois oui
mais en général mais c'est pas mal parce
qu'on voit la réaction des joueurs
[Musique]
donc attends c'est ça marche en marche
aller-retour ou ça marche en score
c'est peut-être marche aller match
retour en fait
pas vraiment parce que ça change rien
attends je vais regarder si il fait nul
il plie pas le match si c'est un match
retour
non c'est un bo4 non non c'est pas mal
de photos sauf 4
c'est bien ce que je pensais mais après
ils m'ont fait peur
il y a quand même des beaux prix
au total le finaliste prend
85000 le troisième 55000 et le quatrième
40.000 et puis les autres prennent aussi
de l'argent ce qui m'a été mis avant
jusqu'au 8e
bon après écoute pourquoi pas ils
organisent chez eux ils prennent un
joueur attention
soyons bien d'accord
et il avait raté maths contre moi donc
mon doublement sympa
il fait plaisir
mais en fait c'est un match on dirait
pas qu'il y a match quoi c'est juste
mais juste je crois qu'elle mette en 3
et en plus je me rends compte je pouvais
pour dégoûter mais du coup je me lève
pas je fais un peu l'air de rien enfin
je suis là quoi il rate et là bon [ __ ]
ça redonne bien confiance du coup
j'avais gagné la partie
alors que je t'annonce que Levan ça a
été annoncé par chescom dans le temps
qu'on va commenter la semaine prochaine
il y a pas français 4 les vannes à
rognanes
les vents qui ne jouera plus qui a
qui déclare forcément
ça Toronto
donc pour des raisons personnelles
comme global Championship et il sera
remplacé par Sam Sevian qui avait
éliminé Maxime
casser un roi aussi
[Rires]
ça c'était quand même le truc
extraordinaire parce que ça je dors j'ai
adoré il a tellement bug
mais
c'est juste le cerveau non
j'en ai vu des gens ont craqué aux
échecs genre taper la table pleurer et
crier enfin faire des trucs de tu vois
que ça craque quoi mais prendre le roi
lui péter sa tête enfin c'est
et puis tu le reposes n'importe où
de merde connard
pour la partie vous l'avez compris c'est
une question de temps maintenant les
pions avancent le roi blanc est faible
il y a une pièce de plus pour les Noirs
normal de jouer après pour Magnus parce
que bah déjà il a rien à perdre c'est un
match et on sait jamais une gaffe et
vite arrivé mais bon ça semble plus que
compromis non mais il trouve comme des
coups pour résister un peu et pas perdre
son temps
[Musique]
non à ce niveau là il y en a peu qui
ratent à notre niveau ça rate mais pas
là
c'est bizarre il fait des gaffes à la
con comme tout à l'heure maintenant
cette partie en fait ce qui est 17h
comme cou mais
[Musique]
finalement c'est le coup qui a fait
gagner la partie au final
ça c'est le deuxième théorème
c'est pas les fous mais c'est mauvais
coup non réfuté devient bon coup
théorème bah allez c'est ça
va changer les dames et pousser non
quand même un peu en avance là
on peut garder les dames mais bon après
voilà
j'avais pas vu
mais ça va je crois
et peut-être une couille en fait là
il a raté c'est sûr
[Musique]
après tu vas revenir en G7 avec la main
il fait flou ici
je crois qu'il y a pas de fuite
c'est pas la technique la plus immaculée
ça comme ça normalement
par chance bien avant
il a même pas B7
non
mais bon
[Musique]
il se met dans une sauce n'est pas pour
gagner ça quand même
tu peux ça peut mal tourner à n'importe
quel moment
c'est très chiant il y a trop d'échappe
et je sais pas je dois avoir un truc où
je suis pas bon dans la vision des
échecs des dames quoi enfin dans les
parcours des dames les circuits
je dois vraiment calculer en fait j'ai
pas la vision
finalement de foot tu peux mettre ton
schéma en place ok je contrôle je bloque
le roi je vais être mon foulalala tu
peux faire ça [ __ ] que les dames tu
peux pas trop c'est vraiment calcul ou
alors pas si tu peux c'est soldat de mes
compétences on va dire trois victoires
non une victoire blanche dans cette
position
mais ça s'arrange bien le match alors
que oui c'était quasi plié en fait
c'était complètement plié enfin la
position était complètement gagnante
pour Manu si il menait un zéro
et tout d'un coup
ça a tourné ça fait un partout dans
l'autre match de zéro il y a j'ai envie
de dire circuler il y a rien à voir
et donc là on devrait avoir une pause et
ça devrait reprendre sur les coups je
crois de 19h45 Fabien si je ne dis pas
de bêtises et surtout s'ils sont à
l'heure donc un petit quart d'heure
voilà ouais là faut que ça enchaîne mais
il y aura peut-être un tout petit peu
plus de pause je sais pas
mais ouais
17h45 heure locale donc je pense que ce
serait un peu plus ça peut être plutôt
entre 1945 et 20 heures à mon avis
ok on fait une petite pause aussi est-ce
que tu veux faire une pause
5 minutes quoi je te propose Fabien de
faire cette pause merci on fait on fait
une petite pause on vous retrouve ouais
dans 5 minutes on vous laisse on vous
laisse la cam histoire de voir un peu le
public on met quelqu'un pour voir les
gens qui font le café
oui
cam public pour voir le public revenu en
nombre pour pour cette de ces
demi-finales et finale de championnats
du monde à Reykjavik
bon allez on fait on fait la petite
pause on revient allez entre 35 et 40
allez ça roule à tout de suite tout de
suite
mon Fab on est reparti oui à reparti
pour ceux qui nous suivent
d'outre-Manche
il y a des Anglais Fab ouais bah souvent
il passe justement
pour suivre ici
et c'est vrai que tu fais bien de parler
dans leur langue pour pour qu'ils
puissent suivre
une manière intelligible ah oui c'est
important donc c'est un partout dans ce
match là on va pouvoir suivre deux
parties encore en diable et
ouais complètement bah écoute c'est vrai
que ça a relancé un peu le match c'est
victoire de peau donc il subit mais bon
pour l'instant il tient le score et puis
bah écoute on a l'abri de rien et il y
en a quatre sont voté par contre lui bon
qui tu penses favoris dans le match
entre entre Yann et Magnus maintenant
après ce retournement de situation assez
cocasse j'ai envie de dire bon toujours
normalement toujours Magnus mais bon en
tout cas on voit que ça peut arriver qui
trébuche les gamins ils touchent les
pièces ouais j'ai vu son trésorerie de
piquer sur la pendule un moment et tout
mais ils sont très heureux en fait
pendant qu'on attend faut pas qu'il soit
aussi timide
donc désolé je te coupais mais parce
qu'il y avait quand même
priorité au direct quand même
non mais je sais pas tu vois pas
on sait pas en fait ce qui est favori
quoi
on n'a jamais su
non mais globalement 45 bon voilà mais
pas grand chose
quand quelqu'un qui marche qui se balade
dans ce cadre idyllique pour pour une
phase finale de championnats du monde
changement de bouteille d'eau aussi
important bouteille rouge c'était des
bouteilles jaunes avant est-ce que ça
peut avantager l'un des deux joueurs
Fabien d'avoir une couleur différente
comme ça sur les bouteilles ça dépend un
peu oui
tu vois souvent tu la places une couleur
vive on voit mieux que ça tient le
regard ça peut déconcentrer donc ouais
ça peut aussi être un facteur on sait
que le niveau se joue sur sur des
détails comme ça une bouteille une
couleur de bouteille une couleur de
bouchon
ça peut ouais ça peut ça peut ça peut
faire une différence change tout ça
change tout
[Musique]
genre Barthès il s'habille en noir pour
être un peu camouflé quoi donc
l'attaquant ça a même pas trop se placer
voilà alors tu as des Gaules qui jouent
en fluo bah là tu t'identifies tout de
suite les caches pas plus calme direct
mais complètement mais là le noir il ne
réfléchit pas à lumière tu dis ouais
est-ce que finalement c'est ouais est-ce
que les cages sont là
et c'est pour ça souvent par terre dans
les gardiens chanceux et les attaquants
tirent souvent à côté mais comme tu dis
c'était le camouflage
il était là
c'est un coup pour les bouchons mais je
sais pas ce sont plus ils peuvent les
dévisser bon c'est pas trop donc ça va
son importance et oui il y a des
secondes comme ça qui peuvent s'égrainer
on verra ça se joue ça peut se jouer à
ça une demi-finale de championnat du
monde
d'ailleurs est-ce que nous on a accès à
la position qui ressort ou pas du tout
je pense pas hein demande un petit peu
trop quand même à mon avis on va essayer
mais bon excuse-moi Fab
pas du tout
faire voilà c'est pour être vraiment
bien sûr si tu étais dommage de pouvoir
un petit peu regarder et discuter des
plans
ça aurait été ça aurait été dommage
restons-en sur les bouchons quand même
quand même plus important finalement ça
aurait pu nous distraire ça aurait pu
nous distraire et il y a un arbitre là
qui qui
cherche quelque chose qui s'agite
il est déjà reparti le temps que je le
repère j'aime beaucoup aussi le rol-up
des logos juste derrière je trouve
magnifique c'est très très réussi
avec une ambiance un petit peu ZAD event
une porte de sortie porte de secours
juste derrière ça nous rappelle des bons
souvenirs les peaux très bien placé quoi
on a tout de suite dit nous que c'était
vraiment le l'endroit principal du Z
event et là encore le petit rolobe comme
ça mais pas mis trop pour pas gêner et
en cas d'incendu ou quoi les joueurs
seraient prêts directement à bondir la
porte juste derrière et avec le ouais
porte sortie de secours très très bien
placé
du coup tous ces sponsors j'en connais
pas un seul en fait quasiment
[Musique]
peut-être des
kebabsaya au-dessus
OK
il y a des médias je ne sais quoi
on ne sait pas en fait
c'est des hôtels
pourquoi tu es au courant stunt
à mon avis c'est des motels c'est pas
des hôtels c'est des motelston si tu es
au courant c'est des hôtels nuits on
connaît on connaît Stan 83A
des hôtels
au courant
c'est écrit en dessous et prenez nous
pour des cons nous on le voit pas écrit
c'est pas du tout écrit en fait
en fait celui qui stitie le mieux c'est
chiasse.com quand même moi je dis ça je
dis rien le seul logo que tu arrives
vraiment à lire c'est chasse.com
l'option vert là qui se reconnaît de
très loin Dany il paye pas pour rien
déjà il paye pas et en plus il te met le
logo aussi je veux dire au bout d'un
moment c'est quand même une maison
sérieuse ici
en fait Rennes il a juste récup à
l'imprimerie le relais il a dit rajoute
moi de chaise quand même là en dessous
du truc noir tiens regarde celle-là
c'est sponsors ferme-la c'est c'est
sponsor de l'événement
qu'est-ce qui découvre la puissance
du GMMP plus forte que la HD
je me mets plus près ah ouais ouais je
me rapproche
plus de loin le stream a défoncé la vue
merde
je vois plus rien
j'en ai absolument rien à [ __ ] en même
temps mais je vois plus ouais c'est
assez stressant
on reconnaît bien le logo litchi
on est pas sûr peut-être c'est un cheval
on sait pas
JETCOM il te met et le pion et ils
écrivent à côté ils prennent un max de
place ils en ont absolument rien à
[ __ ] mais ils ont raison en fait c'est
Marlow
merci Monsieur il fait un petit coucou
nous aussi
il est ils sont venus les deux jeunes
avec leur papa
ils sont là en premier premier rang
des très beaux fauteuils aussi qui sont
là pour pour le public Fab
ah oui magnifique
c'est marrant que tu es quand même moins
de monde pourra changer le monde que
pour une sale battle à Paris mais
[Musique]
c'est vrai
tu as moins de monde et le cadre est bon
ouais non c'est étonnant parfois
oui
ce serait déjà en train de chanter
il est pas frais le poisson
une entreprise de photocopie qu'est-ce
que ça fait là
il y avait plus de monde dans le public
c'est pas possible
avec un peu ce manque d'ambiance c'est
un peu triste je trouve top ça donne pas
l'impression que c'est un championnat du
monde tu as l'impression que c'est en
fait ça donne l'impression pourquoi tu
regardes mes pensées si la finale de
Roland-Garros c'est 4 pélo dans le dans
les publics
mais moi non plus en fait c'est ça qui
est beau
la personne est au courant en fait
et personne n'a envie d'être au courant
c'est ça qui est magnifique en fait
c'est grâce à au courant et puis quand
tu dis aux gens il y a un changement
mais en fait j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
de mon weekend
on va changer d'heure donc elle demande
d'ailleurs c'est une inventaire parce
que si on change pas d'heure en Islande
là
OK
attends on peut mettre on peut la voir
la pause en fait avec la cam vas-y la
magnifique on va réfléchir il me demande
[Musique]
c'est tellement sûr
de l'autre côté avec du kg 3 qui va
surgir non mais c'est sûr que c'est C4
C5 B4 B6
attention à quel G3 qui F5 okh5 ça me
laisse pas très vite en danger 7
j'ai 7 n'est pas protégé donc attention
on t'aime tactique
signal tactique là attention
c'est soit F4 soit c'est 4 façons mais
je pense ils ont plutôt faire ces quatre
serait beau que c'est toujours la même
chose en fait c'est beau Jacky tu crains
un piège quand même
toi tu ferais tempo non
bah tu tombes sur un con que
je suis là vraiment il y a peut-être
dame 5 qui va qui va sauver les meubles
mais
pas loin quoi
c'est vraiment dans la sauce ah bah
peut-être c'est déjà fini
fais voir c'est pas juste être gagnant
en un coup on a réussi à la position de
départ ou pas des fois après ça
c'est peut-être trop demander quand même
évidemment on n'a pas on peut la créer
là c'est vraiment relou de la crème
ok j'ai 3 qui est tu peux pas enlever 7
c'est incroyable
non on aurait été tellement heureux
donc du coup c'est sûr qu'on n'est plus
il va te mettre
[Musique]
mais ouais donc ok c'est 4
mais du coup tu peux commencer par kg
mais le problème c'est que c'est 5 c'est
un coup parce qu'il y a de 5 qui protège
tout
je peux pas faire
et j'ai trois C5 F4
ou un truc pour défendre comme ça
c'est peut-être position qui avantageuse
au blanc mais du coup que j'ai trois
peut-être tu forcément jouer un truc
comme F5 comme ça cahier H5 tu as des
rois F7 ou du Tour Eiffel mais t'empêche
le rock et je sais pas en fait du coup
façon tu es contente casser la symétrie
à ce jeu ça c'est un truc je suis sûr
mais bon
[Musique]
si tu veux
voire même fou bout j'ai petit rock
ouais
bon ok
c'est intéressant
quoi
c'est censé déjà avoir commencé en fait
ils sont en retard
c'est incroyable
on n'est pas les positions un peu plus
un peu plus tôt
supporter de santé
[Musique]
vous avez perdu en Coupe de France déjà
vous avez fait comment on a perdu
c'est quel c'est quelle vision c'est 8e
division
donc bon je sais pas c'est de la merde
mais bon de toute façon on n'allait pas
aller bien loin dans cette compétition
donc
ouais mais bon faut attaque envie de
passer deux trois tours de vibrotech
quoi bah de toute façon
tant mieux et puis bon
ouais tu as envie de vivre roter
non ils ont mis la meilleure équipe qui
pouvait même
pas que tu mets les U19 avec 3 pro quoi
ça tu joues à 100% et tu fais 0,0 à
domicile contre Rodez
ouais en fait comme dirait ils ont
réussi à rendre le truc un peu relou
enfin
il y a trop d'attente en fait c'est pas
possible
c'est long en fait
tu imagines ça fait trois heures déjà ça
va pas du tout ça va absolument pas
c'est pas possible en fait ça peut pas
intéresser les gens
non mais ils sont débiles dans je sais
pas comment dire en fait mais c'est tout
le temps en fait c'est juste tout le
temps et tout
ça
un peu moins longue je vais jouer les
deux matchs en quinconce
tu as toujours une partie en cours
tu vas plus vite quoi
[Musique]
on a trouvé un peu
c'est pour ça en fait
sinon
annoncé les horaires en fait une partie
à 17h une partie à 18h une partie à 19h
partir
oui mais bon si tu annonces tu fais quoi
à la con c'est jamais au silent
même quand je suis refait un semi rapide
du coin il peut être en retard pour la
première ronde parce que les mecs
viennent pointer trop tard moi ok mais
après ils mettent le turbo quoi ah bah
oui ah bah oui non mais là c'est tu peux
pas faire enfin là ils ont fini à 24 tu
fais quasiment 40 minutes de pause dans
un truc rapide ça n'existe nulle part en
fait c'est pas possible on joue les
parties quoi et puis on rattrape et puis
machin petite pause midi allez hop ça
reprend à 14h à 14h d'aller prendre son
nom c'est ta ta remise des prix pouf
aller tourner chez toi quoi non mais oui
mais en fait ce que je veux dire c'est
dingue que n'importe quelle rapide
n'importe quelle bled soit mieux
organisée que ça
je suis d'accord avec toi
et c'est pas dur
mais c'est les échecs
c'est les échecs mon Fab
et c'est bien chiant
surtout là on est on est complètement
bloqué
on est complètement bloqué
[Musique]
j'ai envie de dire la parade
hôtel
tu vas pas pouvoir faire grand-chose
[Musique]
mais oui c'est un peu chiant
on va parler un peu du de l'événement la
semaine prochaine alors
donc c'est quoi déjà le nom du truc ou
les Vans
le nom du truc le nom du truc global
du monde de Blitz sur internet en gros
en gros ouais bon sauf que pas vraiment
mais bon voilà et
c'est quoi il y a combien de joueurs
OK et on va faire des poux des cartes
finales et je sais plus hein
deux endroits différents
du coup ça se retrouve à deux endroits
différents enfin c'est ouais
écoute on verra on verra mardi quand on
y sera mais je crois que c'est des
poules j'en parle un peu pour meubler en
attendant qu'il revienne et en fait ils
refont comment ces garçons avec les
Blancs ça c'est encore bizarre je trouve
dans minima tu changes à mi-match
non mais c'est normal en fait c'est
normal ouais ok
c'est pour équilibrer l'avantage
est très heureux ça c'est hyper fort
c'est déjà gagné en fait je peux pas
défendre l'option
[Musique]
on va voir faut que la partie se lance
en fait je peux pas refresh la position
je pense savoir recommencer enfin je
pensais que ça recommence à 20h du coup
mais ça a commencé encore un peu plus
tard mais là ça devrait repartir
manus qui tente des choses avec ses
coupes de cheveux
ouais il aime bien
ça lui va pas mal après
tu peux faire plein de choses tu veux
faire le rocker quoi il doit faire un
peu le
faire undercut aussi sur le côté garder
la masse au centre
n'est pas lui qui a été tenté la queue
il a sa bouteille c'est autorisé ça a
l'air de bouteilles
[Musique]
il suit déjà un épaules
j'ai trois C4 c'est deux coups
et j'ai trois plus tricky c'est 4 juste
normal quoi
quand même beaucoup d'argent en jeu
presque 100000 balles si tu gagnes ou
pas ils applaudissent leur dégoûter quoi
non pas cette fois-ci cavalier
c'est pas beau quoi
c'est le four en G8
F5 c'est 4 ok il a décidé de faire
l'expansion des pots
alléluia
et il suit avec ses deux ailes en fait
c'est logique c'est logique
il y aura tellement de mal à sortir sa
dame
mais il va suer avec les cavaliers il va
sur avec beaucoup de pièces
avec la dame avec les deux cavaliers il
va suer avec toutes ses pièces en fait
juste
ce que la dame V8 et le cavalier à 8 je
sais pas trop comment tu les sors mais
ils sont ils sont loin
qui posent une question sur notre
premier coup qui est G3 on va le faire
F5 donc
tu fais comment en fait déjà tu peux
faire G6 parce que tu montes ton roi et
tu vas l'attraper
donc
en fait vient des villes
tu peux faire G6 maintenant bah au pire
voilà je suis d'accord
au pire tu fais ton truc maintenant si
tu as envie et au moins tu as provoqué
c'est pour ça en fait qu'il a fait j'ai
ok on a compris
incroyable quand on y pense et
d'ailleurs que j'ai trois on peut pas
faire F4 alors je pense que tu fais pas
F5 dans ces cas-là non tu fais pas mais
tu fais ces 5 peut-être
alors
c'est 5 tu bloques
puis tu veux ce que tu peux
OK
donc c'est pour ça qu'il a fait j'ai 6
mais c'était dur ça à voir
mais il continue à jouer tempo on s'en
fout
non mais c'est marrant c'est logique ce
qu'il fait mais peut-être c'est pas bon
j'en sais rien avec des cavaliers dans
les coins qui font rien est-ce que tu as
le choix c'est ça la question est-ce que
tu peux vraiment agencer
prendre le centre c'est rarement mauvais
peut-être il veut juste un plan simple
et bête comme vous aussi ce qui va aller
F7 et même petit rock peut-être il faut
F6 il attend de voir
donc Magnus va aussi faire petit rock
après tu fais ces 6 des 6 dames et 7
dame 7 qui avait laissé cette fin tu
reviens
tu reviens partout
on a parlé à tout c'est pareil dans le
chat alors on va pas vraiment passer la
voir dans le sens où ce match là est
très serré et intéressant et exactement
il a fait 4 à cet endroit là mais bon
je pense c'est bien pour Abdou sa torov
si réussi enfin d'avoir une position
aussi déséquilibrée parce que tu peux
peut-être gagner avec les Blancs
et comme ça à la dernière avec les Noirs
tu peux faire un online même si ta
position est mauvaise au début tu tentes
un truc quoi ça tombe bien pour lui de
commencer ça avec les Blancs
pas le match est terminé donc oui au
moins c'est réglé
j'aime pas trop non plus
F3
qui était le coup principal de leur dire
tu veux simplement développer ton fou
mais alors
il est déjà développé en fait non
je ferai juste des six ou F6 ici
développement simple et logique
peut-être je vais faire des
et 5 et ça se empêche le
mais je sais pas
moi je sors tout quoi
forces plus ou moins 2 mais bon c'est
pas un coup tu as pas non pas avec les
Blancs tu as plus ou moins envie de le
faire aussi quoi
ça permet petit rock ouais mais bon ok
pourquoi pas
et après tu réfléchis
tu penses qu'il va jouer relativement
rapidement l'année à l'époque
il faut aussi c'est pas logique
je pense pas que tu puisses jouer avec
grand rock en réalité il y a trop de ça
donne du coup la dame et la tour serait
trop bien placé
c'est 5 tu valides et 5
Mike tu veux te ramener vers F4 et
versez-vous vers F6
il veut il veut quand même continuer
avec ce plan là mais il a ramené le
cavalier en dessin quand en premier
bon au moins il est plus rapide mais
à vrai dire maintenant quand il fera ses
6 il aura en quelque sorte développer
ses pièces E4
en fait ce qu'il veut c'est lui enfin
c'est le c'est lui mettre le roi mâle de
tous les côtés de l'échiquier c'est ça
en fait ce que tu vas faire cavalier F4
tu vas te faire rock
un moment donné tu sauras reprendre du
pion et tu vas vraiment suer en fait à
ramener ton cavalier
ça a l'air d'être kata en plus
[Musique]
c'était un peu trop optimiste pour les
Noirs un truc plus recroquevillé
peut-être été plus recommandé
la différence c'est qu'on a la dame bien
la tour 5 qui joue avec les Blancs
il y a des grosses pièces comme tu le
disais qui sont loin du jeu pour le
moment
on est moins bien on est vraiment moins
bien avec les Blancs ici
avec les morts pardon ici
peut-être direct pour pas laisser
respirer
ça peut être une partie Express celle-là
pas même le temps en fait de le
récupérer le pion tellement les noirs
sont sont pas en place
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment la
position de base là qui est simplement
mauvaise pour les noirs
difficile
voilà on nous demandait on nous a
demandé dans des lives précédents s'il
arrivait qu'il y a des positions à 960
tous les blancs sont réellement
nettement mieux dès le début je crois
qu'on en tient une
trop gros problème
il a commencé par cavalier B3
pas après le truc au moins ils ont
équilibré le problème entre en jouet
blanc et noir la même position oui donc
bon même c'était mal et bah c'est la vie
après je pense que là c'est plus
avantageux d'avoir joué en blanc en
premier
parce que du coup tu vois vraiment un
scénario de merde
et tu pourras essayer de
faire autre chose mais je crois que la
partie va turbo fini
comment rattraper le temps perdu quoi tu
mets vraiment une position de merde au
noir ça finit son 10 minutes quoi
il y a moins de nuls avec les ordures en
960 bah en 900 balles par exemple sur
les quatre parties il y a eu quatre
parties résultatsives
décisives il y a pas il y a pas eu de
nul forcément dans les échecs modernes
les mecs sur récitent 20-25 coups de
théories ont des positions égales après
25 coups là en 960 dès le coup deux ou
trois temps un joueur qui peut prendre
l'avantage avec toutes les pièces sur
l'échiquier donc il y a plus de
c'est un vrai jeu là en fait
tu joues l'autre en fait tu peux jouer
des parties ou tu ne joues pas c'est à
même assez fréquent et même quand tu
joues tu as déjà des indices parce que
tu sais ce que tu es censé faire tu as
déjà analysé le truc
il a fait des cartes
bon je veux dire pour jouer aux échecs
c'est un très bon jeu
pour jouer une partie du jeu d'échec
il se fait tellement prendre à la gorge
ok il résiste il évite l'enfermement du
fou il défend un peu sain qu'il aura un
peu Saddam bon ça donne pas envie mais
il perd pas sur le champ après un jour
si réussi je sais pas si ça se décante
un peu au centre et que tout d'un coup
il part avec grand rock bah c'est tout
ce qui est à mon avis ouais c'est de
pouvoir partir avec un grand rock un
moment donné
et une fois qu'il aura le roi à l'abri
de ce côté là peut-être même contrer
aller droit bon c'est un vœux pieux mais
puis on prend il gagne le pur F5 tu agis
une connerie et tout d'un coup tu fais
grand rock et bim tu débarques avec la
tour et la dame mais c'est toi qui
attaque
c'est le seul espoir je pense de Yann
ici
mais c'est pas encore totalement terminé
il y a encore ce petit ce petit espoir
qui fait vivre
ce qui va commencer il faut ranger 3 je
crois que c'est je prends
qui est très mal placé parce que ben oui
mais bon c'est toujours le théorème
il va être du mauvais côté et le
cavalier F4 qui est beau
et ta dame B8 elle est dégueu mais
bizarrement elle peut peut-être un jour
participer au jeu après je pense la D5
ok
ça peut
ça peut être tout ce dont reviennent
d'ailleurs il est de nouveau debout
c'est pour ça que ça joue pas il se
barre c'est particulier quand même de se
lever comme ça en rapide aussi souvent
j'ai du mal à comprendre Fab l'idée
derrière cette bougeotte
peut-être que ouais
mais il a souvent eu une attitude un
petit peu désinvolte
Yann il a souvent une attitude un petit
peu désinvolte mais peut-être qu'il lui
enlève aussi une pression forte qui
ressent lorsqu'il joue
en tout cas c'est en train de partir
dans la variante qu'on vous énoncez
comme quoi Fab on n'est pas toujours à
côté de la vérité
qui va permettre
ayant d'avoir une position qui peut lui
plaire alors j'ai l'impression que sur
grand rock direct qui a lieu cette fait
mal
l'impression que c'était dégueu d'avoir
ça dans ce temps-là mais bon il y a pas
forcément de suite
du coup l'ordi il fait quoi sur Grand
Direct
bon il envoie juste des cinq et il
attaque quoi
oui mais
pas mal encore quand même non
de toute façon il faut ok là
bah écoute direct va te faire [ __ ]
à laisser cavalier 7 en réalité ça doit
être la question qui se pose
bon
si tu te dis de toute façon tu vas le
prendre et cavalier de tes pas sûr tu
prends on prend et là il va et là il est
obligé
c'est la position qu'on a aimé c'est pas
il y a quand même quelques petits trucs
et un pion de plus pour les blancs mais
il y a ce petit tu vois genre même G3
t'as pas il y a cavalière si je pense
là il y a le cavalieras et H3 d'ailleurs
en revanche si le Cavalier Blanc
commence à se diriger vers les cases
après j'ai l'impression que c'est quand
même une chimère cette attaque noire
mais bon
c'est absolument dégueulasse la position
tu peux faire kéger 5 en fait aussi que
vous pouvez écrire
et tu donnes beaucoup de pièces tu
donnes beaucoup mais bon
mais tu peux aussi avoir des idées comme
je sais pas disons un truc comme ça ça
tu peux aussi
j'arrive pas à le faire marcher
mais
je voulais dire un cavalier H3 dame
prend H2 à un moment donné
j'arrive pas à le faire marcher
c'est bien
réussi à faire des quatre et à
plus une qualité mais
mais il a des Punto
on ne sait pas
Magnus qui se remet mal au temps enfin
tu vois le truc c'est position elle aura
quand même rester difficile d'un point
de vue pratique à jouer niveau il se
garde du temps
il joue tempo il va te mettre la
pression il va espérer comme dans la
partie précédente une gaffe est
top à la vachette
[Musique]
vraiment l'addition de la vachette dans
ces parties
en fait évite la vachette et tu viens
jouer quoi bah en plus la vachette irait
direct sur Carlson quoi il a le drapeau
rouge il a le bouchon rouge alors tenez
beau la bien enlevé donc il était très
malin pour pour esquiver la vachette
il a un beau drapeau de la fille il y a
pas de rouge dessus il est très bien
quoi enfin je pense qu'il reste assis
tranquille il bouge pas et Magnus qui va
qui suit
il fait fou ces deux d'ailleurs c'est
une des difficultés à interview des fois
il y a des vachettes elles sont prenait
un mec je sais pas trop pourquoi
peut-être son odeur je sais pas mais des
fois tu as des gars c'était terrible
juste pour te dire maintenant c'est
avantage noir d'après l'ordi
absolument rien à [ __ ] il te prend le
Punto
mais je pense que contre l'ordi on prend
vraiment 10-0
je pense que tu peux rien faire contre
l'ordi je pense tu te fais défoncer
parce que là il était vraiment bien avec
les Blancs
à quel point on est nul en fait aux
échecs quand on a plus notre petite
théorie et nos 40 coups d'ordinateur
en réalité tu parles d'une position où
tu as plus un direct
je pense en cinq coups tu peux te
retrouver quasi perdant
3 c'est invisible
même en langue attention tu peux pas
penser à ces trucs là
en fait on arrive à pas mal jouer parce
qu'on a des schémas en tête et qu'on
réussit à les reproduire et qui sont
plus ou moins vrai et on les a acquis
grâce à des années et des décennies
d'expérience des siècles d'expérience
mais quand on perd cette expérience
c'est impossible de jouer et c'est là
que tu te rends compte aussi Fab que
qu'à l'époque les anciens joueurs ils
étaient vraiment forts bah oui
parce qu'ils avaient pas cette théorie
tous ces bagages sont en ouverture
évidemment mais en milieu de jeu en
finale comment jouer contre tel
structure quand tel truc quelle pièce
échanger ils en savait rien quoi il
cliquait
donc oui
si on parle de filidor par exemple il y
a hyper longtemps c'est incroyable
c'est fou en fait
bon même dans les joueurs plus modernes
jusqu'à
capable en cas et qui tout ça c'était
hyper Fortini qu'il a tellement apporté
et après c'est de plus en plus sérieux
mais j'ai envie de dire juste enfin tous
les mecs avant de toute façon les ordits
tout ce qu'ils ont arrivés à comprendre
à trouver tout ça c'est extraordinaire
c'est incroyable
et on le on le ressent bien
dans ces parties
la difficulté du jeu d'échec quand on
n'a pas le bagage théorique qui va avec
finalement nous sommes petits face à
l'immensité de cet océan exactement
ok le problème c'est que tu as pas d'âme
G5
et de les et de jouer ça mais ça tu
joues pas regarde il s'est levé n'est
pas genre
ouais j'imagine il veut faire ça ça ça
ça
et ça
et ça a pas été joué mais bon puis on
est pas trop mal avec les noirs
il se barre il en a absolument rien à
[ __ ] mais Magnus si tu perds celle-là
avec les Blancs tu suis quand même
ça va être dur parce que c'est la
position de merde et
c'est qu'il a réussi à garder cette
réputation de joueurs pas très fort dans
la théorie alors qu'il est préparé c'est
le joueur le mieux préparé du circuit
non mais c'est une fausse réputation
même à l'époque ouais parce qu'en fait
il jouait ses ventes de merde mais
beaucoup analysé et c'était pas des
trucs réfutés qui jouaient c'est juste
il jouait pour amener son style de jeu
mais c'est déjà énorme en fait d'un
étant adversaire sur ton terrain et de
pas te prendre des nuls forcés et
compagnie
du jeu et bah oui non il est prépa
laisse tomber
donc c'est une réputation
c'est un beau joueur bien préparé et là
on va voir si sur un jeu entre
guillemets sans théorie ici à mettre à
mal le champion russe qui ont le
rappelle c'était fait écraser dans leur
duel mal du championnat du monde n'est
pas qu'il y avait implosé en plein vol
et qui peut rendre dans cette
demi-finale de championnat du monde la
monnaie de sa pièce à celui qu'on
appelle le saumon
mais qui est plus un viking sur les
chéquiers
la magie qui paraît être le coup et on
voit avec cette tour en H8 que tout d'un
coup tout d'un coup la dame B8 commence
à connecter sur la case H2
et c'est jouer
et ses jouets alors là la casse c'est
plutôt la case F5 c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire
et là il faut qu'il trouve cavalier C4
ouais c'est des coups difficiles ou
cavalier
[Musique]
c'est trop dur même en longue
une [ __ ] d'intuition
puis surtout qu'il y a ici quatre B5
aussi qui peut faire peur
c'est la même oui mais bon enfin
j'arrive il faut quand même vérifier
tout
bon après ok c'est pas con de réfléchir
longtemps parce que Pierre tu dis je
fais de toi
après nul c'est vrai que tu es content
dans cette position d'avoir les blancs
la deuxième hein
tu peux pas avoir
oh le level ça a dû vibrer fort
attends
j'ai une nouvelle
dépêche AFP
tremblement de terre à Reykjavik
tremblement de terre avec
7 sur l'échelle de Richter
Richter évidemment
ouais c'est beaucoup trop
[Musique]
c'est quoi l'idée en gros bon il a une
menace simple c'est qui déjà c'est une
fourchette et il veut te connecter un
cavalier avec un dame prend H2
voilà Magnus il doit suer avec avec 8
minutes
à la carlstène
je pense dur pour son ego si en deux
championnats du monde de
960 avec à peine 8 jours si jamais à
gagner
je sais pas c'est chiant quoi
qui joue mais mais
bon il a pas encore perdu le match ni la
partie d'ailleurs mais ouais oui
évidemment ça va l'embêter
ce que ça a quand même dans le petit
monde des pros et tout tu dis c'est
quand même les vrais échecs je sais pas
comment dire ouais
est-ce que tu es si fort que ça ah bah
en fait non
après c'est juste un jeu un peu
différent et ça correspond probablement
moins aux qualités de Magnus qui est
plus un joueur stratégique qui est Rudy
comme tu le disais qu'un joueur tactique
même si calcule bien ou quoi mais
ça le favorise moins quoi ouais voilà
c'est le talent brut c'est le talent
tactique pure
c'est une forme du jeu d'échec en fait
qui va lieu de ça va partir à tempo
tout reprend de tempo ça me prend H2 et
il va se prendre toute la ligne
en fait je crois qu'il a tout jusqu'à
KB2 qui avait pris en D1
ça se voit au langage corporel ça se
voit que nepo est gagnant
tranquille comme dépôt et tout calculer
en plus sur le temps de Magus entre
guillemets parce qu'il le laisse
réfléchir
il lui envoie tout un pot
il va faire dans ma chambre
sur échec parce que sinon c'est surtout
reprendre le direct il y a dame prend
des sept maths attention
ça devrait pas être raté ça par Yann
non
mais
ça peut pas être plus fort en fait
en ligne droite c'est que des échecs des
prises
après un cavalier
très clairement
pour être bien sûr quand même Fab
tu me fais ça en partie
enfin c'est quand même très gentil mais
bon tu vas quand même tu vois
non mais
en tout bien tout honneur
on va quand même vérifier deux trois
petites choses quoi
mais est-ce que tu es bien sûr
il a défoncé là [ __ ] c'est incroyable
en fait
ça quand même l'air d'être juste de la
merde complètement
mais en fait plus tu te penches dessus
tu dis bah en fait il y a ça il y a ça
il y a machin ouais ça arrive par-ci et
c'est pas facile de trouver des coups
quoi en tout cas ça nous offre de belle
séquence tactique ça va être assez
incroyable tu imagines le cavalier C4
qui va les prendre C6 donc qui te tu
menaces la dame tu menaces là tu as
l'impression que tu vas gagner et tout
d'un coup tu te prends ce truc dans la
gueule
et sur roi H1 il y a cavalier Yamaha
éventuellement puis on prend plutôt
et donc et donc on doit le prendre ce
cavalier en E2 et là cette dame en B8
qu'on disait complètement perdu qui
revient en jeu et qui termine la partie
en elle toute seule
incroyable et vu à part un épaumiation
en deux trois minutes incroyable
il va y avoir juste mes pensées
t'as même pas de casse pour ta tour
après il va y avoir Dame des deux ça va
ouais
mais bon c'est très bien
à [ __ ]
RAF
je clique
alors que Manu c'était si proche de
gagner ce match
[Musique]
on va on va jeter un petit œil très
furtif Fab pour voir est-ce qu'il va y
avoir un match ici aussi
pas fait encore pour
il est bien mais c'est pas fait OK
et en plus mal au temps
[Musique]
et de toute façon en fait combien même
je veux juste montrer un truc on va
faire dame 5 tours H2 en fait quand même
tu ferais dame 8 3c7 dame
Lordi affiche un avantage de 10 points
pour ne pas bon c'est enfin c'est sûr
quoi c'est roi mâle qualité de plus il y
a rien qui va
dur dur pour Magnum
ouais machin on va voir que le groupe de
Carlson était beaucoup plus fort avec
Carlson Naka
le truc c'est que les autres vous avez
chaud quand même qui est censé être bon
bon il a raté son tournoi c'est comme ça
mais il a gagné le temps l'an dernier
donc je veux dire il joue bien ça et
voilà après bon c'était qui le quatrième
plus beau mon quoi je sais pas ce qu'il
faisait là
c'est blueba
ils sont venus jouer
et c'est abandon
c'est ciao victoire de Yann qui
réfléchissa après fou au 4 pour un peu
se [ __ ] de la gueule de Magnus il a
bien faire ça les joueurs quand ils sont
complètement gagnants des fois pour
prendre un ascendant psychologique pour
la suite
ça fait mal et on va aller voir
maintenant il a complètement jeté les
pièces en fait regarde cette caméra Fab
tu vois j'ai pas vu mais
non mais ouais
mais bon
ce qu'il y a une vérification pluggetsk
actuellement
le médecin a été appelé sur place Fab
il serait spécialiste de proctologie
mais cela ne nous regarde pas
ça peut et on va voir si Abdou réussit à
terminer lui sa partie
il est encore un petit peu de suspense
dans ce match
on dit que petit à petit
mais bon
ça règle le calif3
[Musique]
visuellement ça a l'air pas mal
ouais ça a l'air beau
ça a l'air absolument magnifique
ça va ça a l'air absolument magnifique
mais bon on se fout j'ai un qui est
bloqué
pour le moment
tu t'y attendais toi à ce
cette domination de Yann dans le jeu
tactique
non pas vraiment
la gaffe en fait on le sent
on sent qu'il peut faire une grosse
erreur mais sinon dans le dans le jeu
dynamique on le sent plus
d'avoir un meilleur
instant exactement tu m'as enlevé le mot
de la bouche
non je sais pas à quel point aussi juste
il a une énorme réussite parce que là
dans la partie
elle a senti qu'il faut qu'elle allait
vite de merde il allait l'amener vers F4
et donc bien joué que en fait ça aille
mais bon
il a une bonne intuition quoi
c'est comme Maxime les pièces sont
toujours bien placés dans les positions
dynamiques en réalité
[Musique]
ils ont ce feeling ils ont ce feeling
enaka est un peu le même truc
qui arrive à optimiser leur pièce en
fait dans des positions chaotiques voilà
genre là je sais pas en fait finalement
la tour B8
qui va arriver vers B2 qui se connecte
avec la Tour Eiffel 2 tu sais pas enfin
tout d'un coup il se passe des trucs
je sais pas
en tout cas ça va être sympa la
quatrième partie de voir si
comment je vais pour lui dans une
position
à faire quelque chose
d'où ça t'auras en fait si même là avec
les Blancs gagnantes il réussit pas à
retourner Naka de ne pas cher de sa de
sa peau quand bien même il gagnerait
va bientôt arriver au 30e coup on est au
26e
[Musique]
moi je la mettrai pas mais bon
c'était quoi je t'aurais pas compris en
fait moi non plus j'ai pas la race
en fait quand tu sais pas quoi faire
pousse un pion de l'aile
c'est 5 là ça a l'air fort
[Rires]
même ça en fait c'est pas forcément
intuitif
ok je sais pas
c'est magnifique mais bon
le meilleur du monde
c'est dur à dire mais Caro peut-être
et Maxime il est pas mal aussi
pas tout à fait le même style je sais
pas en fait carreau quand il y a
vraiment pas trop de temps il voit
vraiment vite en fait c'est plus de la
tactique purica ou par rapport à
dynamisme
c'est pas c'est pas la même force en
fait
c'est la même base mais pas développé
pareil
mais je crois qu'il a un talent très
particulier en fait là dedans
je sais pas comment il a fait en fait
c'est
c'est ça
il va encore s'en sortir
et il va filer tout droit en finale non
mais ça a l'air d'être un jeu pour lui
quoi le 960
tailler sur mesure
calcul pure mais quand tu mixtes ça
reste femme ah bah oui
960 ouais mais comme tu vois ça attire
pas les foules par exemple aujourd'hui
pour une demi-finale de championnat du
monde après je crois qu'il y a pas
beaucoup de monde sur twitch globalement
avec les vacances scolaires les trucs
les machins en ce moment c'est un peu
Halloween quoi
ouais en plus c'est le weekend de la
Toussaint et tout là il y a vraiment peu
d'audience en français sur twitch genre
vraiment tout le monde mais de toute
façon 960 les gens regardent peu ça leur
plaît pas trop
mais là tu vois demi-finale de
championnat du monde on est 1600 alors
comme je disais pour aujourd'hui il y a
vraiment très peu de monde partout donc
c'est on serait plus un peu plus
normalement mais
mais ça reste ça reste peu
[Musique]
dynamisme c'est du dynamisme enfin c'est
difficile d'expliquer
des mots en fait qui définissent des
choses je sais pas trop comment
expliquer le dynamisme que c'est
tu sens où mettre les pièces et qu'elles
vont agir quelles fonctions ouvertes on
va dire ça comme ça
optimiser tes pièces quoi la dame B8
donnée pour qui est tout pourri
l'arrivée à trouver comment la rendre
utile pour visage
il y a des places sur les candidats en
ce moment là non pas du tout là c'est un
tournoi complètement indépendant
c'est un autre circuit en fait un autre
jeu
mais ça en fait en soi pourquoi pas
c'était pas absurde
mais il se trouve que non
mais en fait je trouve c'est une bonne
idée mais il aurait fallu qui d'autre
calife que de faire sur internet à
l'arrache comme ça c'est complètement
l'arrache là tu fais un vrai truc avec
trois quatre ans dans l'année
qualificatif avec des points marqués des
8 meilleurs machins enfin tu en fais une
sorte de grand prix de 960 mais bon
rapidos sur un week-end tu fais pas
jouer des semaines entières de trucs et
puis et puis voilà pourquoi pas en fait
dans ce sens-là
ils ont pas ils n'ont pas participé mais
je crois qu'ils jouent très peu en les
tournois sur internet que soit ml ou
firuja
pour des raisons qui semblent
évidentes
à prendre de l'ampleur petit à petit moi
j'y crois pas mais après je peux me
tromper
non mais en fait vraiment longtemps que
ça existe ouais et que ça a vraiment pas
pris enfin ça a compté le début de fin
bon Richard
il y a 30 ans on va dire
sauf que
il commençait à avoir quelques tournois
il y avait minds une époque
très sympa
mais c'était une fois par an il y avait
pas trop d'autres trucs
moi une fois j'ai fait un tournoi un
stand en 2005 c'était au fin fond de
l'Espagne c'est un beau festival où il y
a un tournoi de Blitz ton mode rapide
ton mode de Random de chasse et
d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et deuxième temps que j'ai fait c'était
il y a deux ans donc en fait en 14 ans
j'ai pas joué une fois
alors que j'aime bien le jeu il y a eu
des tournois je les aurais fait mais
donc c'est juste que ça joue jamais quoi
ah bah moi aussi j'aurais préféré jouer
à 960 c'est plus marrant
qu'elle se taper masse de théorie mais
non non le jeune n'a pas pris je dirais
que il a même régressé plutôt au début
il y avait un espoir et puis en fait on
a bien compris que personne jouait quoi
et dommage mais c'est comme ça enfin
pas des fois faut se plier à la réalité
voir l'arrêter comme elle pas comme
j'aimerais qu'elle soit donc j'aurais
bien aimé que le jeu marche et qui est
plus de temps là mais il se trouve que
non et ben faut pas c'est comme ça
c'est surtout une paire de vitesse des
échecs oh là non
le 960 là ça a aucun rapport enfin c'est
une évolution sur 30 ans
c'est pas un truc sur six mois
même pendant le boom il y avait eu le
championnat du monde de 960 l'an dernier
et il y avait nettement moins de monde
que pour tous les autres tournois qui
avaient été suivis dans l'année ça a
toujours été même
qui était revenu qui avait fait le tour
à 960 tout le monde s'en foutait alors
que c'était Gary quand il faisait encore
ses petits come-back qui était
intéressant comme c'était un come-back
en 960 ça intéressait personne ça a
jamais intéressé les gens en fait
mais même quand on faisait je sais plus
est-ce que c'était pas des confinement
des fois on faisait les aprèm on faisait
des petits tournois on avait fait une
formation on faisait que des Bleus c'est
plus une fois on a dit tiens vas-y on
fait 960
c'était juste les gens ils voulaient pas
y jouer donc c'est même pas que le
regardait c'est
non non quand tu fais quelque chose
sur un laps de temps court tu vois que
le 960 c'est
donc bon bah c'est comme ça enfin c'est
pas comme je vous dis on c'est dommage
j'aurais bien aimé c'est un jeu que
j'aime bien et si vous vous aimez bien
je vous ai dit ça peut développer de la
créativité d'essayer de bien agencer les
pièces de se débrouiller mais
ouais malheureusement ça va pas
révolutionner les échecs
ouais mais pour les amateurs je
comprends que ce soit flippant le jeu
déjà compliqué la dès le premier coup tu
sais même pas quoi faire non mais c'est
trop en fait
c'est trop dur quand tu es vraiment trop
amateurs mais après un moment ça devient
sympa quand tu es amateur justement mais
que tu as que c'est limitant de devoir
trop travailler la théorie et que tu te
fais défoncer par des gens qui font que
ça
et là d'un coup tu dis ouais mais moi
j'ai juste envie de jouer aux échecs
j'ai pas envie qu'on me récite mais
c'est tes petites conneries là et
là c'est intéressant sauf qu'en fait je
pense que il y a très peu en termes de
nombres ça fait peu de joueurs en fait
mais je sais pas parce que je crois que
j'ai vu une stat complètement folle sur
bah je crois que tu avais mis un tweet
dessus
quand tu as dit quand on est plus de
2008 ça il faisait les pourcentages par
rapport et que déjà tu es plus 2000 tu
es peut-être déjà dans les 80 %, quoi
enfin ou un truc de ouf comme ça c'est
peut-être même plus de 2000 tu es dans
les 98 % 99 je crois que c'était déjà 99
tu vois donc ouais alors que
oui et donc du coup moi j'imagine que
les gens dont je parle c'est des têtes
des mecs entre allez minimum 2000 entre
2000 à 2500 quoi ah ouais ça représente
0,1% des joueurs c'est ça le problème
mais c'est quand même pas mal de joueurs
qui vont jouer en tournoi et qui sont
amateurs et qui justement peuvent
souffrir à cause des ouvertures
donc pour eux ça sera un jeu qui qui
serait mort à jouer enfin juste tu veux
jouer aux échecs et tu joues aux échecs
mais c'est ça le problème c'est que si
tu représentes très peu de monde ça
représente personne
et surtout dans ce talent aussi beaucoup
de gens qui aiment quand même les
ouvertures
même si les ouvertures il aime quand
même parce qu'ils ont leurs ouvertures
quoi
c'est genre ta petite carte d'identité
ton ouverture je sais pas ils aiment
bien
ça a été joué
[Musique]
et puis tu proposes nul parce que ça
gagne le match
non dommage pour le pour le petit là
mais casque qui me défense de fer en
face et il a bien bien sauvé le truc et
donc ce qui est ici pour la finale
la première fois de la partie
et puis
fini
un truc pour faire un échec en Russie
mais tu mets le roi en C8
et après c'est le Punto qui parle à tour
qui va revenir couvrir par derrière et
le pion a qui va partir ça va être
abandon pour ça
je pense qu'il y a juste prendre à deux
en fait
je vois pas de pourquoi pas le faire en
fait
s'il fallait gagner faudrait peut-être
encore faire un tu aurais peut-être fait
tout reprendre à deux tu fais un petit
effort mais là on est en besoin de faire
nul
tu ramasses
une fois que tu prends des seins
le seul source de
problème dans la position puis on reste
toujours aussi faible
tu peux tout faire il y a rien à dire en
fait c'est
tellement bien que contre lui je fais
encore gaffe
non mais moi
je crois qu'il y a rien à faire gaffe
de faire cavalier F3 ok il s'écasse
en comptant si tu veux gagner là pour
faire nul c'est sûr que
[Musique]
un peu en tout cas et c'est abandon
c'est acté victoire d'Icare un camion 3
Punto à zéro ça te RAF qu'on retrouvera
quand même demain pour la petite finale
ça a été dur contre
un peu dans le même registre en réalité
mais beaucoup plus loin
mais
il ne reste plus que que les deux qui ne
se quittent plus car elle n'est pas bien
chi ça va être la dernière partie de
cette journée à moins à moins que Magnus
légalise et nous offre un Armageddon à
enchères
qui se retient assez sympa mais moi
j'avais envie de voir une victoire de
Yann avant le match
je reste sur
même je pars pas tout le temps tout le
temps ça pour le mettre en confiance et
voilà
il va pas le rejoindre
le prochain
c'est dingly Rennes son prochain
adversaire on a toujours pas les dates
de ce match championnat du monde qui
sera probablement annoncé vraiment à la
à la dernière minute Fab ouais
ça serait bien quand même
il y a quand même une certaine logique
mais je veux dire au moins quelques mois
quoi après bon on se doute entre avril
et juin je sais pas trop mais
bon
non mais juste pour les joueurs qui
puisse bien se préparer et qui prennent
pas des engagements ailleurs ou je sais
pas enfin c'est la moindre des choses
déjà quoi après
si bien de
la veille
on va pas faire une pause pour Naka et
abdouk dans le match
donc je pense que ça va reprendre
rapidement
complexe
on va attendre
ça a la même position ouais il joue
aller-retour les positions c'est fait
pour que si tu as un avantage c'est la
position d'un avantage blanc de base que
ça équilibre le match
là c'est une règle logique
donc on va on va attendre
on va attendre le retour de Fab et le
retour du match regardez s'il y a des
infos importantes mais non apparemment
est-ce que cette position vraiment un
avantage blanc
on vient de prouver avec la partie
précédente et on a bien expliqué avec
Fab pourquoi les Blancs étaient mieux
malgré la symétrie
donc
dans là on est une position on va on va
remontrer quand elle va être à l'écran
quand les joueurs vont arriver pourquoi
le carré des G3 donne davantage au blanc
quand est la finale sera demain 16h je
pense
jamais simple mais je crois que ce sera
16h
en même temps que nous c'est pour ça
donc c'est compliqué
bon genre qui ne change pas d'heure
carrément
le même problème la semaine prochaine
avec le tournoi qui se peut soit 17h en
fait
mais il change une semaine
et une autre avec une autre heure je
sais pas il faudra voir
complexe
a pas l'air de reprendre pour le moment
dommage quoi
parce que là vraiment pas besoin de
faire une longue pause et l'ont déjà eu
leur pause et on pourrait récupérer un
peu le retard et donner un peu dynamisme
surtout que la partie d'abdo elle était
pas si intéressante que ça au final
Mathieu déjà dominé par NACA il avait
besoin que du nul
ce truc là tu peux leur dire vous jouez
pas la quatrième ou c'est pas grave
tranquille
ah bah ils vont pas la jouer
ça va bientôt revenir
j'imagine
complexe
je crois qu'ils sont en train d'arriver
ça y est Magnus
qui est là
on va voir on va voir la position
comment ça 21h15 bah là je crois du coup
qu'ils ont accéléré
oui ça sert à rien enfin
ça sert à rien
[Musique]
si les capacités déployées pour jouer
aux échecs qui se transpose dans la vie
de tous les jours et si oui est-ce que
tu as des exemples concrets à donner moi
je pense pas et toi à part peut-être la
prise de décision mais sinon
je crois pas non plus en fait mais
aux échecs ça sert à jouer aux échecs
mais c'est quasi tout
spécialement de transposition par
rapport aux autres scolaires quoi donc
après je veux dire si tu joues à petit
niveau ça peut te donner une forme de
[Musique]
de système de pensée de chez ma pensée
pour les résolutions de problèmes ou
quoi tu peux peut-être réutiliser
certaines choses aux échecs dans ta
manière d'aborder un problème dans la
manière de le résoudre dans les dans les
étapes intellectuelles à apprendre mais
en fait une fois que enfin être
professionnel après progresser aux
échecs ça te sert qu'à être meilleur aux
échecs ça ne sert absolument à rien non
après ok peut-être niveau concentration
de faculté d'abstraction de choses comme
ça mais
c'est pas fréquent dans la vie de tous
les jours ce soit très utile on va dire
en tout cas que tu joues un petit peu en
amateur un petit peu en club que tu sois
1400 1500 ou que tu sois grand maître ça
va t'apporter les mêmes choses c'est ce
que je voulais dire
ça peut t'aider aussi si tu as des
problèmes de concentration effectivement
à prendre à se concentrer et ça peut
t'apprendre ce genre de choses en fait
mais ça peut se transposer plus dans les
dans les qualités dans les capacités pas
promment dire intellectuel en tout cas
pur mais mais plus dans l'approche que
tu peux avoir de de des problématiques
plus dans le comportement en fait que ça
peut t'aider que dans le que dans
l'intellect puis réduire
mais
[Musique]
comme ça pourrait t'apporter comme
quelqu'un d'autre sport si tu les fais
sérieusement en réalité le sérieux la
compensation la rigueur la discipline
déjà à petit niveau on va dire tu as pas
besoin de
complètement
pas forcément fort en cours mais qui
découvrent qui sont talentueux sur ce
jeu ouais ça peut aussi mais bon comme
on estime tu peux l'avoir
n'importe quoi d'autre en fait ouais
mais ça peut après
que comme c'est relié dans l'inconscient
des gens à l'intellect enfin peut-être
que d'ailleurs il y a un lien ou quoi
j'en sais rien passé à voir tu peux dire
ok je vais peut-être pas bon à l'école
mais je suis pas forcément débile pour
autant parce que je suis fort à un jeu
intellectuel etc mais en soi c'est pas
plus valorisant de bien jouer aux échecs
bon à autre chose si on a envie enfin
je peux vous assurer que les échecs
travaillent énormément ce qu'on appelle
les fonctions exécutives la mémoire qui
permet de manipuler des informations
simple par exemple on joue avec stunt un
jeu de mémoire hier je pense que j'étais
dans les plus nuls
moi je pense au contraire que les échecs
ça détruit ma mémoire naturelle en fait
mais bon
la tête ça dépend à quel niveau c'est
pas un cadeau en fait à petite dose oui
ça peut travailler un petit peu tout
mais comme tu as d'autres enfin d'autres
manières de les travailler mais à haute
dose je pense pas que ça améliore la
mémoire du tout en fait d'ailleurs je
demande à quel point de
faire le dos en fait ça prend pas sur
d'autres choses et que tu élimines
d'autres facultés pour
spécialisé quoi
mais genre même Vlad sa mémoire dans la
vie de tous les jours est absolument
catastrophique
comme si les échecs ça lui avait
complètement rempli le cerveau en fait
tu penses qu'on a une place maximum
comme un genre un ordi et qu'il faut
c'est un genre de fatigue mental et que
un moment donné en fait ça t'a tellement
que tu peux plus en fait ça t'a
tellement connecté les neurones entre
là-dessus et tout que ça top
en fait avoir une bonne faire beaucoup
d'échecs pour la mémoire ça permet juste
d'avoir une bonne mémoire quand tu joues
aux échecs pas plus en fait
peut-être mon con avec tous les jours
bah c'est très possible
pour le coup en fait c'était pas enfin
je sais pas personne dit ça mais c'est
pas enfin je pense c'est quand même pas
mal de jouer aux échecs
mais c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas obligé
de jouer à trop de doses
[Musique]
regardez ça en amateur c'est bien quoi
si tu travailles via les échecs genre
moi par exemple ça me met vraiment pas
quoi
je sais pas vraiment très des vrais
études scientifiques qui le prouvent
j'ai pas de mémoire mais je suis pas sûr
soit grâce aux échecs toi tu as une
bonne mémoire globalement il refait mais
tu vois je peux pas dire soit grâce aux
échecs ou pas enfin
j'en sais rien c'est peut-être que c'est
comme ça quoi
je peux dire que j'ai toujours eu des
problèmes de vision en 3D et que je joue
aux échecs ça va pas du tout améliorer
les
améliorer d'ailleurs je joue mieux sur
je vois mieux les pièces
en 2D mais
[Musique]
en fait ouais un petit dos c'est bien
mais à grande enfin faut pas se prendre
la tête enfin s'inventer une Life et se
prendre la tête en faisant je joue aux
échecs ça me rend très intelligent
c'est pas du tout le cas après
à petite dose c'est c'est sûr que c'est
bien enfin j'en suis convaincu pour
avoir appris à des enfants et à plein
d'adultes à jouer et très souvent tu as
le discours de ça m'a quand même aidé
notamment pour la concentration c'est
quelque chose que j'ai souvent entendu
ou pour résoudre des problèmes j'arrive
mieux à planifier les étapes à
à faire en avance en amont donc pour ça
clairement les échecs ça apporte quelque
chose mais comme je le disais ces choses
que ça t'apporte très rapidement dans ta
pratique
et pour la concentration aussi
donc
c'est un avis assez logique
donc il a fait ce F6 il doit vouloir
essayer de jouer un autre type de
position après l'avantage quand tu veux
jouer le lien avec les Noirs comme je le
disais un petit peu plus tôt
c'est que c'est pas du tout comme aux
échecs qui peut pas te faire sécher il y
a toutes les pièces sur les chiquer donc
tu peux même si tu es un peu moins bien
dans l'ouverture remonter puisque
il y a de quoi faire
mais c'est hyper logique ce qu'il fait
mais des fois il en a rien à [ __ ] il
clique en fait
je pense c'est vraiment pris la décision
pour pour lui-même ce jeu est trop
compliqué au début tu arrives pas à
savoir ce qui est bien et ce qui est pas
bien autant tu joues tempo et tu vois ce
qu'il arrive après
je pense c'est vraiment ça son leitmotiv
et c'est bon il supporte pas ce que dans
les coins je crois
pas du tout
ma position est très complexe tu la
senses
5 il va disons FC ok H5 G6 qui est H6
c'est compliqué
il peut peut-être avoir du foussé d'eux
aussi à un moment donné pour aller se
taper
5 je pense que cavalier F5 c'est quoi
qui a F5 G6 cavalier H6
ok il peut se retrouver un peu bizarre
en tout cas Magnus j'ai l'impression
qu'il s'en est bien sorti là
pour régler les problèmes vers le droit
peut-être un truc qui leur a pu faire
tôt c'était F4 avec les Blancs
ça prend un peu d'espace
oh que oui
mais faut faire attention de pas faire
comme Abdou il se retrouve complètement
bloqué
peut-être un peu ce qui est en train de
lui arriver ici n'est pas je vais
peut-être un peu vite
pour ça qu'il faut peut-être quand même
faire cavalier F5 ou cavalier C2 et pas
aller sur cette case F3 qui serait une
chimère
le
oh c'est dur comme décision qui est
[Musique]
ça arrive vite vite vite vite
après
la dame elle est pas il y a trop de
pions mais là Magus il a réussi à
prendre le centre avec les pions en
réalité ça fait très mal
n'est pas qui a qui suit tout simplement
pas de bonne case pour ce cavalier en
réalité F5 tu vas aller perdre la barre
en H6 non mais pas trop mignon ouais
c'était de trop
un peu trop vite trop
il y a peut-être repartir vers ces deux
cavalier F3 bah attention fougère
avantage mais comme il n'a pas réussi à
le sortir de la partie à un moment donné
il lui a manqué
j'ai 6
mais il veut pas se prendre
est-ce que tu fais un cap pour garder
ton pion B5 ou est-ce que tu fais H4
pour avoir peut-être du foie H2 pour se
mettre en face de la dame
franchement pourquoi pas tu essaies de
garder ton besoin de plus c'est un peu
ta seule à sale gloire
et après tu fais H4 il faut acheter
je suis d'accord avec toi surtout que
quand le fou va venir en H2 tu vas
appeler un déplacement de la dame
puisque tu auras quand même une balle
diagonale tu auras peut-être des dégâts
de ces trucs comme ça donc quelque part
c'est un peu con de faire H4 fois H2 et
tu l'appelles en B5 en quelque sorte
qui est la même idée
qu'au hasard mais bon après il va
trouver une réaction centrale il fera
des trois ou B3 ou 4 ou je sais pas quoi
enfin il va il va les pousser des pions
[Musique]
ton histoire de H4 c'était pas bête
quand même
idée c'est jusqu'à 4 je voulais me
rajouter un peu de H5 oui mais c'est ça
[Musique]
il fait pas la même erreur que
ça tord à
fond H2
mais ce centre noir fait peur hein cette
marée de pion là cette nuée de pion j'ai
même envie de dire
c'était sain de pion
peut en trouver des synonymes ici
moi il va ok je pense
dommage pour lui qu'il puisse pas mettre
le four à 4
mais il va il va essayer de péter les
pions après il va faire B3
les enlever les uns après les autres
ça a commencé par des trois
je pense qu'il est stressé qui va pisser
en fait
donc on a le petit rock un règle
spéciale au 960 pour qu'on puisse roquer
on va vers la tour que ce soit la tour
de gauche ou de droite et on se place on
place la tour et comme sur un roc
classique donc roi G1 Tour Eiffel pour
le petit rock roi c'est un tour des un
pour le Grand Roc
tout simplement
[Musique]
qui m'ont confirmé que c'était juste les
nerfs quoi il va il va souvent pisser
d'après Vlad n'aime chier
je t'attendais pas à autre chose la part
de Vlad non
[Rires]
logique tu m'en veux en plus
donc il y a plus d'histoires de quoi
enfin on peut quand même faire B3 ou je
ne sais quoi si on veut mais je veux
dire au moins le pion de C4 n'est plus
cloué
4 ou P3 1 2 3 coups
bah écoute des quatre c'est quoi c'est
juste on se barre c'est un peu comme
l'attaque Spike
[Musique]
j'ai peur qu'on soit sans espace de rien
quoi
du coup j'aime autant faire des trois ou
trois pour pas laisser tous ces trucs à
arriver
genre CD tour c'est vite il prend
et peut-être trouver
il y a des choses quoi
4 B5 on fait un
pion3 et on peut peut-être claquer
quelque chose en fait pas même des
quatre quatre qui est Pro 4 et après tu
as les fous quoi
il a fait
ça j'aurais même pas considérer le coup
en fait je comprends pas l'idée
il me faut
[Musique]
il stoppe dégage il se dit ok je m'en
fous je vends des quatre
je sais pas trop enfin c'est bizarre je
suis étonné du coup mais bon
Fd1 D3 petit à petit mais je pense je
ferme la fenêtre
il va voir
[Musique]
après je sais pas ça très bien
mais bon et maintenant B3 mais le 3 je
trouve vraiment superflu
je comprends pas non plus ce temps n'a
pas besoin en réalité non
mais ça donne même des cases il est même
mieux en eux ce pion tu as plus de
flexibilité Flexi sécurité je vais faire
deux trois je vais faire le droit tu
sais pas
non je sais pas trop ce qui l'entête
après bon écoute
[Musique]
on est parti d'avant à trouver des trucs
donc je vais pas lui jeter la pierre je
sais pas mais c'est pas très convaincant
quoi
non c'est
juste son grand parle le fois H2 par
rapport aux fautes qui sont les mêmes
fous au début
Magnus c'est beaucoup logique où il l'a
mis quoi il est pas embourbé
au système de Londres quand tu te prends
le mur là parfois enfin quand système de
Londres contre D6 30 mais le mur là en
face c'est ton X2 il règne jamais été
très content quand il y a un coup comme
F5 ou 4 en réalité mais sauf que là tu
as même pas le pion dès que tu es oui
c'est horrible en fait
ça semble être catastrophique comme
position
mais c'est un jeu j'avais prévenu tu
peux pas
tu peux pas assurer en fait dans ce jeu
c'est pas possible en fait tu peux pas
même si tu as les blancs tu peux pas
venir et dire je joue nul c'est pas
possible
c'est un jeu où c'est un combat direct
mettre le fond en deux ouais mais
oui mais alors tu as pas de rupture en
fait
en fait tu rêverais de jouer des 4 et de
te faire jouer ton flou mais tu peux pas
il y a la prise en passant alors ça
c'est vrai que c'est un coup un peu un
peu particulier je vais le montrer mais
là le pion avance de deux cases et c'est
un cas spécial aux échecs où tu as le
droit à un autre pion et seulement un
autre pion a le droit de le de le choper
au passage c'est maintenant que c'est
maintenant ou jamais ouais
tu as le droit au passage de le prendre
et là là tu vois il est complètement à
l'envers gagne il a pris il a pris la la
partie du mauvais bout alors après il
peut peut-être s'en sortir il est pas
perdant il est juste moins bien mais il
partait d'une position avantageuse ouais
mais là du coup ça joue clairement
[Musique]
du côté aussi c'est cool pour Magnus
quoi
c'est plutôt plutôt à l'avantage de
Magnus bien évidemment qui va pouvoir
entamer sa longue séance de pression de
massage de pression de massage ventouse
technique norvégienne portant
on se fout H2 et tu aurais envie de
libérer F4 peut-être pas
ah ça va pas comme il est
peut-être un coup qui va donner à une
respiration
ni de vouloir prévenir j'ai 4 G5
qui libère le fou en tapant bien joué
sur H5
est-ce que un fou c'est deux pourrait
être jouer avec l'idée sur cavalier F7
alors maintenant cavalier D6 peut-être
et fougen ici enfin pas sur kf7 mais tu
m'as compris
pour profiter de ce pion qui a disparu
et maintenant
la présentation il pourra reprendre
aussi
et peut-être des cahiers ce qui est B5
pour repartir par là-bas attaquer ça
faut aussi l'interdit et tourbé 5
alors qu'est-ce qu'il veut
oh je crois que son idée c'est tout à 5
tours C7 cavaliers des 4
pour faire jouer le fou par procuration
oh c'est très bien joué ça
qu'est-ce que c'est bien joué
peut-être juste en D8 en D7 alors mais
bon les blancs sont quand même content
de mettre la tour à 5 je pense ça va
moins mal que
il lui était
je préfère quand même les Noirs
là bon il arrive un peu à créer
[Musique]
parce qu'il craint deux trois trucs qui
est en train de toucher son cheval le la
chute qui va mettre en F7
je pense que ça continue par tour à 5
tours
en B5
tu es quand même content avec les Blancs
tu t'es débarrassé d'une pièce alors que
tu es en manque d'espace et tu as
récupéré un foodcas blanche
oui
tu auras 5 sur C7 cavaliers cavaliers
des 4 semble intéressant
il va pisser mais le pire c'est que
c'est possible
non mais c'est clairement un truc
nerveux de toilettes
pas beaucoup pisser
[Musique]
plus une position de 960 maintenant ou
là si dans quelle position tu peux avoir
un four en H2 alors que tu as encore le
pion des deux
mais ça paraît quand même complexe
mais bon c'est vrai que ça ressemble un
pas trop mal
de Londres de machin tu as quelques
trucs mais tu aurais jamais cette
position là normalement c'est là non
mais ça paraît difficile tout F1
je m'attendais tellement à tout à 5
je veux dire
qui vont venir mais au pire tu fais tour
à 5 ans
si jamais
bon sinon il veut juste jamais mettre à
tour à 5 il veut faire à 4 à 5 et entre
la colonne bête je pense c'est plutôt
son plan
ça peut être aussi ça le truc
mais bon
exactement
il avait peut-être cette petite
opportunité tactique
étonnant d'avoir il a pas dû voir le
cavalier des quatre en réalité
mais bon quand bien même quand tu vois
pas en fait tu dois pas laisser
d'options
en plus qui est peut-être meilleur va il
se trouve qu'il est meilleur d'ailleurs
mais par principe tu dois pas faire même
si tu sais pas pourquoi
mais je sais pas
pourquoi il a fait ça comme ça étonnant
après il y a aussi beaucoup de fatigue
qui s'accumulent c'est un jeu qui est
très exigeant Fabien
le 960
après il y a rien de catastrophique dans
ce qu'il a fait on reste elle est pas
trop mal une petite pression tu as
ramener l'autre tour c'est une colonne
et voilà bon bizarre quoi c'est un autre
mauvaise pièce
et le pion des deux je dirais
j'ajouterai
tu réussiras faire des quatre sans te
faire prendre en passant ou même tu fais
pousser un très passif mais qui défend
le pion
et qui pourrait repartir de l'autre côté
si tu as besoin ok c'est tranquille
par roi G7
bouger 5 G4
pour mettre la pression sur le cheval
pourquoi pas
sur G5 il faudra peut-être tenter fouger
6 mais c'est complètement
une idée c'est de venir en baisser avec
le cavalier tu venais avec tempo il a
joué à l'envers là
mais du coup même si tu fais ça tu étais
content avec ce cavalier là qui la
torsion c'est ça tu vois
donc oui oui non ça va pas alors de
couple
inverser les écrans bande de nazes mais
écoute
décidé de regarder comme ça les moi j'ai
regardé il est hyper visible c'est
tu vois tu vois les joueurs en grand tu
vas aller chiquer en petit pour les gens
qui veulent regarder les images dans les
images c'est qu'il va les chiquer ils
ont les chiquer après
aussi assez logique de voir les deux
joueurs quand même cette confrontation
entre deux hommes
dans le public
ouais c'est peut-être lui en fait il
joue aux échecs c'est pour ça ouais
[Musique]
je pense pas
en Islande en fait
[Musique]
une nouvelle fois les coûts dit un peu
marrants qu'on voit pas je les monte de
temps en temps
lorsqu'on fait ce
960 parce qu'ils sont très durs à voir
c'est qu'il est BD4 et qui décaille puis
on prend cavalier prend touche le fou
mais ta que F5 et tu te fais prendre en
finale et si tu fais cavalier de 8 pour
protéger il te fait x 4 et tu as plus de
casse pour la tour et tu vas te prendre
aussi et tu reprends des 5
absolument introuvable c'est impossible
de le voir mais très joli donc on
profite un petit peu de
de ces échecs 960 pour voir ses
combinaisons très inhabituelles qui
tombent quand même assez fréquemment et
qui ont les joueurs qui ont un taux de
réussite de 0 % sur ce genre de combine
4 un bâtiment
en fait après si on te dit tiens très
haut blanc c'est un exercice trouve ce
qu'il faut trouver tu vas conserver des
coups bizarres comme ça mais c'est ça la
difficulté à personne qui vient te dire
bon sauf si tu vives mais on soit
on soit hippoca au courant qu'il y a un
truc à chercher et bon regardez qui est
Descartes dans une position comme ça
faut avoir envie
il a fait à 3 un contrôle B4 sauf si tu
vibre ouais c'est ça stunt
non mais après c'est sûr que tu regardes
si le cavalier bouge les cavaliers prend
le 5 ou quoi qui eux sont plus ouais
très dur c'est de voir le X 4 en plus
quoi c'est impossible
tu crois pas en fait
ça le problème comme tu peux avoir
l'idée si le fou aussi se peut pas
bouger qui je te reprends des 5 mais
déjà en fait il est bien défendu mais en
plus c'est vrai que des 8 qui
vient j'ai vu la cam mais je suis pas
sûr qu'il l'ait vu
juste avant
je pense pas c'est un peu plus simple
il doit penser à autre chose qui qui le
rendait mais pas ça c'est trop dur
il a joué quoi j'ai pas vu le coup on va
le voir arriver
on n'a pas le qui arrive on va le mettre
sur la cam échiquier sur la carte il a
joué 5 hein qui est le coup logique en
réalité
voilà déjà tu peux faire un petit
poubelle si un jour si tu as besoin
il y a plus de pièces magiques en D4
complexe
c'est jouer ou c'est toi
ça me semblait logique comme cou en soit
[Musique]
ces pièces sont quand même bizarres le
truc quand aux échecs c'est que quand tu
as pas le centre tu étais tellement mal
organisé
tu peux te faire repousser et tu tapes
dans du granite
ça te coupe tes pièces en deux en fait
c'est comme une armée qui serait coupée
en deux
tu as des gars là j'ai pas tu as un
genre d'équipe rouge les mettrai là et
une équipe verte quoi
a priori les rouges sont plus forts
j'ai regardé si ça joue à côté
qui sert à rien ils auraient pu
bon je trouve ça bien qu'il joue pas en
fait
tu prends B6 tu fais une qualité en fait
il te bouffe à ça tu prends
[Musique]
je me suis pas rendu compte que j'ai
pris deux pièces parce que il prend à ça
oui tu as pris deux pièces là et tu as
pas perdu de matos en fait on n'a pas
perdu à ça
donc c'est trouvable
ouais après bon est-ce que c'est plus
fort que A4 moi j'en sais rien enfin à 4
ce sera le coup qui part avec la main
quoi je veux dire mais
[Musique]